the committee will please come to water
today the subcommittee begins two days
of hearings on the subject of
congressional oversight of covert
operations
more specifically we'll be examining
whether existing procedures governing
the president's authorization of covert
operations
as well as his notification of and
consultation with congress are adequate
to assure meaningful congressional
oversight of such operations
despite the fact that covert operations
represent only a very small fraction of
the intelligence community's work
they tend to generate the most attention
and controversy when publicly revealed
we would all agree that such operations
are appropriate in certain cases
however because of their sensitivity and
potential for controversy at home
it's particularly important that covert
operations be soundly conceived
and be seen as advancing the legitimate
interests of the united states if they
become publicly known
it's for this reason as well as
congress's right to share in the
establishment of u.s foreign policy that
the intelligence committees are involved
in the oversight of covert operations
the primary legislation governing
congressional oversight is the use ryan
amendment of 1974
as amended by the intelligence oversight
act of 1980.
the statute provides that the
intelligence committees of the congress
must be kept fully and currently
informed of all intelligence activities
including any significant anticipated
intelligence activity
this provision establishes the general
requirement that the intelligence
committees must be given prior notice of
any covert operation
however the oversight act then goes on
to create two exceptions to the general
rule
first if the president determines it's
essential to meet extraordinary
circumstances affecting vital interests
of the united states
the president may restrict prior notice
to the house and senate leadership and
the chairman and ranking minority
members of the two intelligence
committees
this group of eight in the leadership is
sometimes referred to as the gang of
eight
second the act recognizes that in some
cases the president may not give prior
notice to anyone but in those cases the
act requires the president to fully
inform the intelligence committees in a
timely fashion
this second exception to the general
rule
requiring notice
prior notice will be a main focus of
these hearings
in the case of the president's decision
to covertly sell military arms to iran
he signed his finding authorizing the
operation in january of 1986
the president not only failed to provide
anyone in congress with notice of this
operation prior to its inception
he never provided notice
it was not until november of 1986 that
anyone in congress learned of this
covert operation and then only because a
magazine in the middle east disclosed it
our purpose in these hearings will not
to be to revisit the entire iran contra
episode that's for other committees to
do however in as much as the president
may decide to initiate other covert
operations it's important for the
intelligence committees to determine
whether existing law contributed to the
breakdown of congressional oversight in
the case of the iran armed sales
of course many of us in congress believe
that the president should have given the
intelligence committee's prior notice of
his intent to covertly sell arms to iran
if he had done so members on both sides
of the aisle surely would have expressed
strong objections
while these objections would have been
advisory only they might have helped the
president avoid embarking on a policy
which was so deeply flawed in its
conception and its implementation
this is a classic example of why prior
notification and consultation with the
intelligence committees are not only a
benefit for the committees but a benefit
for the president as well
however as previously noted current law
does not require the president to give
prior notice in all cases he may defer
notice until after the operation has
begun
but in those cases he must provide
notice in a timely fashion
the problem here is that appropriate
cases for deferring notice are not
defined nor is there a definition of
what constitutes timely notice after the
fact
the subcommittee has before it today two
bills that have been introduced to deal
with these questions
one is h.r 1371 which was introduced by
a former member of the intelligence
committee mr mineta of california
it would require the president to
provide prior notice of all covert
operations
the other bill is h.r 1013 which was
introduced by mr stokes of ohio who was
the chairman of our full intelligence
committee
and mr boland of massachusetts its first
chairman
it's been co-sponsored by all of the
majority members of this committee and
by 49 members of the house
hr 1013 is designed to eliminate the
ambiguities in current law
it would retain the general requirement
that the two intelligence committees be
given prior notice of all covert
activities as well as two exceptions to
this general rule
the president would continue to have
discretion to restrict prior notice to
the so-called gang of eight where
required by extraordinary circumstances
affecting vital interests of the united
states
however the president could withhold
prior notice
only where such extraordinary
circumstances exist and where time is of
the essence
and in such cases notice would have to
be given not more than 48 hours after
the president has signed his finding or
the intelligence activity has begun
thus
under this bill timely notice would be
specifically defined
h.r 1013 would also require that
findings by the president be in writing
and that copies be provided to the two
intelligence committees and to the vice
president the director of central
intelligence and the secretaries of
state and defense
the committee has a very distinguished
group of witnesses to address these
issues we're very appreciative that
they've taken the time to be with us and
we look forward to their testimony
before calling our first distinguished
witness though i would ask mr livingston
if he has any opening comments
thank you very much mr chairman i have
no formal statement
well i
i do sympathize with the
motivation of members who have authored
these bills that are before this body
i
may agree that there are certain facts
that have been uncovered in recent
months that might
prompt
such legislation i have grave
reservations about the implementation
of
legislation of this sort and its
potential impact
upon the the
powers of the president as
commander-in-chief
and so i'm looking forward to hearing
the witnesses i look forward to asking
questions and
i i hope that
we will indeed
unveil
some facts which might uh
broaden our perspective of of what is a
very serious matter i appreciate you
giving me this opportunity thank you
i'd like to also ask our chairman mr
stokes who is the primary author of this
bill if he would like to make any
opening remarks
mr mr chairman i do have an opening
statement but i would yield
if you'd like to recognize the speaker
of the house and i can
yield my statement this time
without objection that would be made
part of the record at this time then
we'd like to invite the distinguished
speaker of the house jim wright of texas
to
be our lead off witness
the speaker has been
interested for some time in a very
capable intelligence capacity and also
in the oversight function which congress
necessarily must exercise
as
majority leader he served ex officio
as a member of the intelligence
committee and
took part in many of our proceedings so
we're delighted mr speaker that you're
here with us this morning
i appreciate the
invitation to come and
talk with the committee
on behalf of this legislation which i
think is
vitally necessary
as i am
have observed the
operation of the
national security act in sections
501 and
502
uh it has become
painfully apparent to me that
certain ambiguities
have been exploited
permitting
activity to occur
which
clearly was not intended
in the
original legislation
the bill you have before you makes two
very simple changes
both of the changes are quite clearly
consistent with the
original intent
of congress
and
creating this committee and this
procedure
for consultation
i recall very clearly when the procedure
was created in law
it was done so at the request of the
chief executive
who felt that
representatives of the executive branch
of government were being required to
report to a
proliferating number of committees and
subcommittees in congress
the president himself wanted
one
repository of this type of information
speaker
speaker o'neill
very assiduously
interviewed and
selected members to serve on this
committee
one of the qualifications for service on
this committee
was
that a person be
capable of maintaining secrecy and
silence
not a
leaking information that was given to
the committee by the executive branch of
government
with regard to
classified
activities
at the same time
it was felt that the creation of the
committee itself
very
clearly implied that the
members of the committee should
serve as a
one part of a two-way conduit with the
executive branch
and that we could
know of things in advance
in order that we might
give our advice
to the executive branch of government
advice and consent
being a part and parcel of the operation
between the two branches
now
i'm quite
sure in my mind that
if the provisions
uh intended in the law and i think
unambiguously
contained in the law
had been followed as congress intended
most surely members of
the legislative branch of government
would have
expressed our reservations to the chief
executive
about the
appropriateness of
this covert plan to sell arms to iran
and quite possibly the entire
embarrassment which has been visited
upon our country might have been avoided
it was that kind of thing that was
anticipated in the
requirement that
there be reports to some limited number
of people
now this bill
the stokes bill
would modify section 662 of the foreign
assistance act
to require that all covert action
findings
be in writing
these written findings would have to be
provided to the house and senate
intelligence committees
the director of central intelligence and
the statutory members of the national
security council
prior to the initiation of the proposed
covert action the bill retained a
provision of existing law which in
certain circumstances
permits
the required prior notice to be given to
eight specified
leaders of congress bipartisan group of
people
rather than to the full membership of
both intelligence committees
as prior notice
i would contend from my reading of the
law
that what was
expressly
anticipated
was no situation at all
in which prior with prior notice could
be withheld from any congressional
person
i don't believe that the
the the the reading of section 501 or
section 502 of our act
anticipates any situation whatever
in which uh all members of congress may
be excluded from knowledge
prior knowledge of what's going on
because um
section 501
1b
in reference to
the requirement
that a
select committee on intelligence in the
senate and the
house
be fully and currently informed
[Music]
is modified only to the extent that if
the president determines that it is
essential
to limit
prior notice
not to
exclude prior notice
but to limit prior notice to meet
extraordinary circumstances affecting
vital interest in the united states then
such notice shall be limited
to the chairman and ranking minority
members of the intelligence committees
the speaker and minority leader of the
house of representatives and the
majority minority leaders of the senate
shall be limited to those people not
shall be
not shall be excluded
not shall be withheld
shall be limited to those people
if these exigencies require it to be
limited
and time is uh
such that uh
members of the committee cannot be
notified now
there have been situations
uh two of which i
could recite to you
in which these uh leaders
were informed
in in a prior
way
when it clearly was not
possible
perhaps advisable to
notify
the full
committee in advance
one of them involved the invasion of
grenada
and on the eve of that uh action
president uh sent representatives to the
uh
capitol
and uh
asked certain ones of us to
uh follow certain procedures by which we
uh assembled them
in the white house
that evening
rather late
and
discussed with the president the
secretary of defense secretary of state
and
certain others
what was about to happen
what did happen occurred at
approximately 5 a.m
and we were
learning of this at about 10 30 p.m or
10 o'clock p.m
when our conversations uh were going on
that was prior notice
complied with the law
surely in a matter of
of that kind
prior notice uh
could be and properly was
limited but it wasn't excluded one
withheld it was given
a second instance uh
involved the bombing of libya
i was out of town
i was in fort worth
and when this occurred
i received a
notification that uh
i should
find a secure telephone
so that at four o'clock
in the afternoon
i might uh
talk with uh people in the central
intelligence agency
uh
representatives of the white house i i
did so the only secure telephone
which i could
establish knowledge in my home community
being a
at the fbi
in one of the federal buildings
and i did so and completed the telephone
call and was advised
of what was
getting ready to happen
it happened within uh
two hours of
my being notified
perhaps with an hour and a half but it
did constitute prior notice
prior notice was given
and so uh
it seems to me that
that this uh
timely uh
notice
then uh
was given in each of those instances to
the committee
after the
action had begun
and that that was in keeping with the
statute
and in in the case of the iran uh
arms uh sales however
there was no prior notes given anyone
nobody was advised
no consultation was held
no congressional party was notified
nobody knew anything about it
until of course it was uh printed some
10 months later
in uh in the middle eastern newspaper
and then at that point uh the so-called
timely notice began to take place
obviously that's not what's intended by
the statute
ten months later after people find out
about it through a leak and a newspaper
that's not timely
notice and so i think it must become
necessary
that to avoid those ambiguities or any
contention on the part of anybody in the
executive branch that timely notice
is fulfilled
by withholding all information until
after a leak
establishes public knowledge
we must define what constitutes timely
notice this has been a breach
and uh
i i think this bill
properly
defines timely notice is not more than
48 hours
that would be reasonable
and it seems to me that
in the interest of maintaining the
right and proper balance the powers
between executive and legislative branch
branches we
we must take this this kind of action
even in those instances
in which the statute
has permitted
a prior notice to be limited
to a certain few
even then
it is quite clear
that the statute requires
that timely notice be given and that it
anticipates that timely notice would be
maybe a couple of days not not months
sure
not weeks and most surely not months
the president shall fully inform the
intelligence committees in a timely
fashion
of intelligence operations in foreign
countries for which prior notice was not
given under subsection a
and shall provide a statement of the
reasons for not giving prior notice
well this bill mr chairman in my opinion
should not have been necessary
as someone who has served ex officio on
this select committee for nearly 10
years
i can state from experience that when
the president legislation was enacted
the congress intended to be notified
before any covert actions took place
and when we used this term timely
fashion and the law
with regard to those extraordinary
circumstances when time did not permit
prior notification the congress meant
a couple of days
not months
the colossal misjudgments made by
some in the administration in the arms
deal with iran confirm the need now i
think for legislation
tightening this law
it is my
honest belief that had the president
notified the congress as to what was
intended in iran
he might have gained a clearer
understanding of the risks involved
had the congress received prior
notification
it is certain
that some of us would have advised
against that unfortunate policy
the united states government might well
have been spared this embarrassing and
costly episode
which continues to undermine our foreign
policy
and so mr chairman i commend your
leadership in holding these hearings
on this important matter and i know that
you're planning the expeditious action
which this
issue warrants
thank you very much mr speaker for your
testimony
we'll proceed under the five-minute rule
questions
mr speaker i think some will argue
that
in certain limited cases particularly
where
life is at stake that is where agents
are
asked to undertake
especially risky operations
the president should have discretion
not only to withhold prior notice
but also to withhold notice beyond 48
hours
that is to give the president some
flexibility
beyond that limitation of time
when he believes that there is an
especially risky situation for
agents conducting the operation
do you believe there's any justification
for
giving the president that type of
flexibility in that type of situation
or
should the president be required as the
bill suggests
to provide this kind of notification to
congress either through the intelligence
committees or to the limited leadership
group of eight i don't i don't believe
that the
statute anticipates
that the lives of uh our agents
or uh any other people would have been
adversely
affected or endangered in any way by the
president's carrying out the provisions
and the statute of giving prior notice
to a limited number of people
i don't think there's any suggestion
that
the lives of
united states intelligence agents would
have been endangered by the president's
giving notice as the law required him to
do
to the chairman of this committee and
the ranking minority member of this
committee
their counterparts in the senate
the speaker and the minority leader
of the house and the majority of our
leaders of the senate
can't imagine anybody suggesting or
thinking
that the lives of american intelligence
agents would be
endangered by the president's giving
that information to that limited number
of people on a prior basis
well let's assume that uh everyone
agrees
that in the case of the iran arms sale
notice should have been given
and that certainly the president could
have provided notice
on a prior basis or within 48 hours
but of course this legislation will
apply to all cases
and the question is whether or not in
other types of situations
let's say
a hostage rescue situation which plays
out over a period of
some days
and in which uh covert activity is
required and
that covert activity places uh the
agents who are involved in the rescue
operation in jeopardy
should the president in that situation
be required
to share that information with members
of congress
well i think that's the hard case which
will be presented with you let's look uh
let's look to the case of uh
of what happened uh with regard to our
abortive attempt to rescue the hostages
in iran
during uh president carter's
administration
in that instance
i am not aware
of whether prior notice was or was not
given to the speaker and the minority
leader
or to the chairman and ranking member of
the house i suspect it was not
i received a telephone call
approximately two
o'clock or two thirty in the morning
from secretary of state uh vance
uh telling me what had happened
uh at that
moment the disaster
had occurred the debacle
of
our misfortune
had just occurred and uh
they were at that time
striving to extricate themselves our
service personnel were attempting to
return to uh
safety of a
uh
of our
our ships
uh
i think in that particular instance
prior notice probably wasn't given but
timely notice surely was
it may have been that
that
timely notice was given
and had it not been given we learned of
it anyway in the most egregious manner
i cannot believe that
if president
carter had
followed the
provisions
explicit in
section 501
of the act
the lives of the rescuers would have
been put in jeopardy
it is conceivable that uh
you know the secretive mind which is
part and parcel of intelligence
operatives
uh and i i don't say that majority of
sense
i'm not saying secretive mind in the
sense that i'm being critical but rather
i'm trying to be analytical
um that they would suppose that telling
anybody
uh in the legislative branch
would put their plans in jeopardy
but that after all is the
warp and woof of uh
the makings of uh
executive arrogance
the idea that um
certain actions are are too
precious to
risky to important to be shared with
congress
well that isn't what was
in the minds of the people who wrote the
constitution
thank you mr livingston
thank you mr chairman uh mr speaker i
appreciate your remarks and uh uh
frankly uh with your regard to your
assessment of the current iranian
situation i
i really don't find much to quarrel with
but i
i am reminded of the old courtroom adage
that bad facts make bad law
and i'm really concerned that we're
rushing to judgment here with a piece of
legislation that is
geared to prevent a reoccurrence of the
circumstances surrounding the iranian
situation
and that will
ultimately cause great harm to
unknown individuals in the future uh by
virtue of our somewhat hasty action
and specifically i guess i'm concerned
about the 48-hour uh
uh provision
uh i'm reminded that you recalled the uh
the bombing of libya and
i'm reminded of the fact that sam
donaldson
uh
minutes
perhaps
as many as
30 minutes or so
prior to the actual bombing was on
television talking
about
a
projected strike
in libya
and in fact
we are not the best keepers of secrets
in the united states congress that's not
an indictment of any single individual
but when you deal with a body as large
as ours with the members with the staff
in fact we just don't keep secrets well
and i'm concerned that there would be
or might be
circumstances
that might arise that uh
might necessitate
the commander of our armed services
keeping the lid on an operation
for much longer than 48 hours
uh and and i use as an example of the
situation that
uh involved the again going back to uh
the first iranian hostage situation
uh the folks who were hiding in the
canadian embassy
uh
in fact there were there were ongoing
operations to try to free those people
over a prolonged period of time
many months my memory serves me
correctly
and i had it gotten out that those folks
were in the canadian embassy lord knows
what would happen to them
and to the canadian
people
i think that uh
i just have grave concerns uh that that
we are seeking to remedy a single
situation
which may have far broader implications
than
than uh our initial objectives uh we'll
just invite your comments sir
well
first with regard to uh
your apprehension
that we might be rushing to judgment
uh
i'd simply point out that it has been
more than four months
since we learned of
what
i believe to be a
clear and unambiguous violation of the
statute
most certainly
all of us would agree a violation of the
intent of the statute the spirit of the
statute i believe a violation of the
letter of the statute
i don't believe that's a
question of ambiguity at all
we learned of that four months ago
those of us who have some responsibility
to protect
the integrity of the legislative branch
in the constitutional scheme of things
i have felt quite strongly for all of
these four months that something must be
done
for this committee in its deliberate way
to have studied and pondered and taken
testimony
and have learned
everything that can be learned
about what happened and why
examine the rationale of those who
advised the president that he
could and should
do as he did
and not advise the congress
in keeping with the statute
we've had four months now
it seems to me that what's being done
here is done in a very deliberate way i
don't believe it's rushing to judgment
i think
this committee as an agent of the
congress is fulfilling its
responsibility
and attempting to guarantee for the
benefit of the nation
and for the
protection of the executive branch as
well
that um
misjudgments of this kind shall not
recur
and that at least we'll have some means
of attempting to dissuade
people from uh
this kind of a misadventure in advance
now with regard to the contention that
there may be circumstances
in which
it would be wise for congress to be kept
entirely in the dark
and i don't know for how long a period
of time you think that's wise
i believe the entire constitution
and the spirit of this law
does not wish to leave that
discretion entirely in the hands of the
executive branch
if you just leave it wide open
and allow the executive branch to decide
when the situation is sufficiently
worthy that it warrants
violating this statute and not advising
congress
is in effect to have no statute at all
might as well not have an intelligence
committee
if if if the executive branch is simply
expected to come when it wants to and
when it's convenient
uh to their purposes
uh and consult with congress
so
unless there is some
[Music]
clear
criterion which the gentleman would
establish
i i don't think it would be wise for us
just to anticipate that circumstances
could arise and and it's up to
someone in the executive branch to
decide if it wants under those
circumstances to advise the congress
in such case who's going to make the
decision
he's going to be the president
he's going to be the
secretary of state is he going to be the
uh chairman of
the
joint chiefs of staff is it going to be
the national security council is going
to be some lieutenant colonel uh you
know
if you leave it uh
undefined
you you you leave it up in the air and
uh invite
this kind of thing again it seems to me
time is up thank you
mr stokes
thank you very much mr chairman
firstly i'd want to express my
appreciation to the distinguished
speaker for his appearance here this
morning and
for the excellent testimonies given on
behalf of
the stokes bowling legislation
mr speaker it appears to me that
in this legislation
we're attempting also to address
uh
a more grievous situation
the government of the offenses as i see
it here
uh
is that from everything that we know in
the public domain at this point of time
the president of the united states
decided
either upon his own or upon advice of
someone
that
this was an operation which could not be
revealed to congress because
congress could not be trusted with this
information
but it's even broader than that
not only uh was congress not trusted uh
members of his own cabinet were not
trusted
so we can't just say it was his
fear of leaks of the congress
but it seems even more grievous that he
trusted
in this operation a foreign nation and
principles in a foreign nation
the ultimate leak came
from the iranians themselves who leaked
the matter to a beirut newspaper
and as a consequence of it this matter
became
known around the world
i would just like to have you address
that broad principle
uh in terms of
of any evidence that that congress in
the case of this ought not be trusted
well
i think that that
comes to the heart of
the balance of powers
perhaps it is uh
inherent in the
executive branch to want to protect the
prerogatives of that branch of
government if i were in that branch of
government perhaps i'd see it that way
but i'm certain in my mind that the
people who wrote the constitution
intended that congress could be trusted
thomas jefferson surely intended that uh
the people themselves could be trusted
that was the heart of the
very
central
core
philosophy of this this government
now
if we were to assume that congress
cannot be trusted
with information
then we betray a lack of confidence in
this fundamental system of ours
it rests upon the assumption that
congress can be trusted
with respect to
the leak which
found its way to sam donaldson
i i think i can certainly say to you
that didn't come from congress i don't
believe anyone has suggested that it did
it
must have come from some other source
i'm quite absolutely
sure in my mind that it did not come
from congress
this committee has been privy to
information
which has not been leaked
until uh much later
and then uh much much much later than
the time when it was made available to
this committee on several instances and
members of this committee will recall
some of those instances
now uh
i should i should like to say
as as as speaker
that if
if it ever were to come to my attention
that any member
or staff person of this committee
had uh
in violation of his
or her oath
uh
leaked information then i would ask that
person to resign from the committee
this is not the kind of committee that
speaker has nothing to say about this
kind of committee on which the speaker
does have something to say
as to the personnel
and i think
all of you would expect that
if there were any reason to believe that
any member of this committee had
violated the sacred oath which is
concomitant with accepting
membership on the committee
then that person should not expect to
serve on this committee along
i just don't believe that's happened i
don't think the house committee has a
has leaked information
we need to be very careful about
personnel people whom we hire on both
sides to service in this committee we
owe that obligation
not to the executive branch per se but
to uh to the united states and
uh to to our oath of office
i would uh i'd recall
an instance
which uh
mr livingston may
be as cognizant of as i am i wasn't in
the congress that time though i'm sure
some of you think i've been here that
long
during world war ii
knowledge of the atomic
arrangements the tests the
experimentation
was held by a very small number of
people
sam rayburn and
the chairman of the appropriations
committee
knew of it and they uh asked for the
money
uh quite frankly saying that uh
uh to the committee we can't tell you
what this is for but we think it may end
the war center
that's all they knew
they provided the money
based upon that information
i think congress can keep uh
confidences
uh if we can't we don't deserve to be
here
thank you chairman mr hyde
thank you mr mr chairman and uh
i have there's so much to ask and so
little time it's an
occupational hazard
but apropos of your last remarks mr
speaker let me quote to you from
november 14 1985
washington post an article by daniel
shore
quote in 1975 the cia's support of the
anti-communist faction in angola also a
kissinger project was disclosed after it
became an issue in the house foreign
affairs committee the late
representative leo ryan a member of that
committee told me in an interview at
that time
that he could condone such a leak if it
was the only way to block an
ill-conceived operation
now i suggest to you that was not unique
with mr ryan and citing chapter and
verse the other day we had a briefing
and i don't won't tell you what the
substance of the briefing was but
march 23rd immediately thereafter page
seven of the newsweek magazine covert
help for cory aquino
the agency will add about a dozen agents
to its 115
member station in manila etc etc etc now
the instances of dangerous leaks
and i don't say they're from congress
but i say that this congress has a
problem that it ought to consider at
least equal to the problem of inadequate
dissemination of secret information and
that is the leak
we cannot keep a secret and a democracy
is in deadly peril in a dangerous world
if we cannot keep a secret
there are many instances here of
enormous violations of
let me read to you from the tower
commission report the obsession with
secrecy
and preoccupation with leaks threatened
to paralyze the government in its
handling of covert operations
unfortunately
the concern is not misplaced the
selective leak has become a principal
means of waging bureaucratic warfare
opponents of an operation kill it with a
leak
supporters seek to build support through
the same means we have witnessed over
the past years a significant deter
deterioration in the integrity of
process rather than a means to obtain
results more satisfactory than the
position of any of the individual
departments it has frequently become
something to be manipulated to reach a
specific outcome
the leak becomes a primary instrument in
that process etc etc now um
i asked richard helms a former
director of central intelligence for
comment on this bill let me read you uh
one thing he says and then i'll ask for
your comment and beg your indulgence
this bill proposes to tighten up certain
reporting requirements on new covert
actions undertaken by the central
intelligence agency
in so doing it demands that presidential
findings be in writing and that a copy
of the written finding be furnished to
certain members of congress and to the
vice president secretaries of state and
defense and the director of central
intelligence at the rate written
documents of the executive branch appear
in the newspapers these days i would
have thought that this requirement
almost constitutes a guarantee
that no action would long remain covert
when a written finding is sent to a
senator a congressman or a cabinet
officer how many individuals on their
staffs actually see this document quite
a few i would surmise put another way
this legislation would further ensure
that with the inability of the executive
and legislative branches to identify
leakers covert action as an option in
support of u.s foreign policy is doomed
this is not necessarily because future
presidents and directors would be
unwilling to take the chance
but because the experienced officers who
must carry out such operations would not
wish to become involved
in what they would inevitably regard as
a no win situation
and then mr speaker he mentions a a
colleague of ours in the other body
who shall be nameless a former chairman
of this of the senate select committee
on intelligence fast idea who it would
be
yeah i appreciate you keeping his uh
identity secret
good i think
i think we have that we'll try to keep
that covert
um
he was quoted in the washington post and
and many other media including the
jerusalem post as having exposed during
a speech in florida an alleged american
intelligence operation in israel now
sure we have a problem congress is
entitled to no we can't exercise
oversight unless the executive has
confidence in us and unless we have
confidence in them and and there is a
problem i'm not sure in fact i'm sure
this is not the solution to the problem
but
we ought to address ourselves to to
security to to
punishing people who leak and devising
ways to find out what the what the leaks
are and who the leakers are
and i'd ask for your comment todd i uh i
think you raise a
really very interesting question
there has to be a distinction
between policy
on the one hand
and the means employed to carry out that
policy
on the other hand
as to the precise and specific means of
carrying out
a covert policy
i suppose congress would be foolish to
expect that we should be
told in such minutia
and detail as the identity of each of
our agents
whom he's contacting
when he's going to take
a given course of action where it will
occur
that would be ridiculous obviously
but at the outset at the inception of a
policy's creation
i believe the law anticipates and i
think the constitution anticipates
that congress needs to have a voice
i don't believe either the law or the
constitution
ever has suggested
that it be a monolithic decision made in
the white house alone that gets us into
a war for example
but that congress should have the
opportunity and does have the
responsibility
to make a judgment as to whether we get
america into a war
now you make reference to
a an article by daniel shore in the
washington post
in november of 1985 it involves
what i would suppose to be a policy
determination with respect to angola
uh
perhaps you and i might agree on that
matter
so far as policy we're concerned i don't
know whether we do or not the point is
that
there is a right for congress to know
that a given policy is being carried out
and congress should have the opportunity
to consult now as to how it's carried
out obviously congress has no uh
reasonable expectation being told
of the manner of it's being carried out
in detail but let me let me uh offer
a couple of other
suggestions
times in which
people appointed in the executive branch
not elected personnel not people
directly responsible to the american
public
have made judgments and launched
activities
that would be unlawful
that would be contrary to our treaty
agreements with other nations
and they quite probably would not be
supported by the congress as a whole
and uh the mid 1950s
perhaps 1954 i'm not certain what year i
think
my recollection would tell me 53 or 54.
the cia
conceived and carried out
an assassination
effort involving a man named jacob
arbans
in guatemala
yahoo orbanz i guess was a
marxist i don't know
just how to define his political
philosophy he was not a great friend of
the united states
it might have been in our best interest
that someone else be elected
rather than he
but an election was
was going on as i recall
and
we have no right to go into another
country
in my judgment
and certainly no person in the executive
branch has the unilateral right to
decide
who in another country should be allowed
to live and who should be assassinated
uh in
1971 if memory serves
in that
time frame in that era
a decision was made unilaterally
in the
covert sanctums of the cia
that we should
go into chile
where
an elected president
was serving uh
peacefully and not attempting to
consolidate his gain to my knowledge
with the use of a armed militia or
attempting to call off regular or free
elections
he was
i suppose a marxist
i don't know that he was marxist
probably he was a socialist
a liberal anyway well i i think that
that is a mild description
uh in any event he was probably not the
person that
the united states in general would have
liked to see president of chile but he'd
been elected president of chile
chileans had voted for him
and i am
persuaded by people who
think they know what was going on down
there
that he would let it alone
he would have been rejected at the polls
and someone more moderate would have
been elected
we wouldn't let it alone uh the c.i.a
conceived a plot to uh
destabilize
destabilize the government of chile now
there's a euphemism for you
uh we we we decided that we are not we
but someone in the uh
in the sanctums of uh the cia decided
that he had the right to
go down and destabilize a government of
uh an elected uh president in chile that
has created bad well for our country it
has a confused
the clarity of our policy it has a uh
contributed to criticism of the united
states subsequently and it ushered in a
militaristic regime in chile
which
still to this day
prevails
it wasn't necessary for us in my
judgment
to have undermined that elected
government in chile
congress didn't decide to do that
congress wasn't giving any choice is
your point mr speaker that we should
leak these things and some we shouldn't
i'm trying to i asked you about how to
deal with the problem of leaks
a recital of the sins alleged sins which
i say are very much in dispute
of the cia how do we deal with
congressional leaks was really my
question i should have put it more
directly henry i think you know the
answer to that
of course you know the answer is not
that we who are privy to this uh
classified information should presume
any right to leak it did i not just say
that we have no right to do that well i
missed it of course i of course i said
that of course i did well we know we
have no right to leak it the question is
what are we going to do about it and are
there any legislative suggestions that
perhaps well henry no what i'm
suggesting is that the congress
does have a right and a responsibility
through the exercise of its orderly
procedures to know what's going on i
stipulate that i agree that
thank you mr chairman and i would like
to congratulate the speaker on his
presentation as well
and his response to questions
i must say myself
as far as the
house committee on intelligence is
concerned
i'm not sure that there's any
example we know of where the house has
uh committee has
been proven to be the source of leaks
we have enormous number of leaks
nationally
and as a matter of fact the acting
director of the
central intelligence
committee recently suggested to us that
the
principal source of leaks is not the
congress not the congress
but mr speaker i would like to talk
about a different
question and it
it's a larger question it is
perhaps i think aggravated by the
tension
that exists between the administration
and the congress in the last few years
particularly although it can exist any
time
and it is the uh
it is a situation which you have
related as
as producing a situation where the
president in his own
in his own mind can elect to comply with
the law or not comply with the law
as a matter of fact i think whether it's
under the war powers act
or notification of covert action even
the two cases you cite
did not involve any prior consultation
maybe minimally notice but certainly not
the consultation
you were not consulted in the sense the
leadership was not consulted
and really there's been an erosion of
the relationship between the
executive branch and the congress in
terms of
some of the most serious activities done
in this nation's name
would you not agree that what is
recommended here is indeed modest ten
years ago for example
when
some of the actions you've just referred
to were reviewed
there were those who asked whether we
ought to
permit covert action whether we ought to
forbid it or whether we ought to have
some mechanism for
congressional approval
or much more stringent prior
notification
so what this is is it not merely a
restatement of existing law to make it
more efficacious
remove ambiguities
so that we can proceed
with a sort of new understanding of the
relationship between the congress and
the and the white house i um i i have
that feeling of course uh mr castmeyer i
do believe that
what is proposed in this legislation is
simply
a tightening up of the statute and in
order to carry out its original intent
i'm
i'm aware of the apprehension that may
have been expressed about the
putting in writing
of
findings
conceivably you may want to think in
terms of uh
how broadly that is to be uh
interpreted
or how widely disseminated
any such writing
but i think it's within the scope of
this committee to handle that kind of a
determination
and
i
i
can find nothing in this
present proposed amendment statute that
violates the initial purpose of the
statute seems to me that it clarifies
and carries it out but that that's my
interpretation of it
back to the to the bill which is uh
before us it it's its intention
basically is to carry out the intention
of the of the existing law
and if you're if you're worried about
uh leaks
then you have that exact problem of
course as mr hyde pointed out so
livingston too to a certain extent have
that exact problem under the existing
law i'd like to remind our colleagues
that a recent study by the by the
intelligence committee of the other
house found out that it
147 recent occasions
of of information having been leaked
that the attributable sources in each in
in all but 12 of those cases
was the administration or someone in the
administration rather than someone in
the congress
there clearly is a problem and and the
larger problem clearly has to do with
the executive branch of of the
government for all kinds of very obvious
reasons
the most obvious of each of which is
that there are very few individuals both
staff and members in the senate in the
house who know these secrets
and in most instances with respect to
most covert operations certainly there
are many dozens often many hundreds
sometimes thousands
of people who know these self-same
secrets which some of our colleagues are
urging us to deny to even eight of the
most trusted members of the of the uh
of the congress and there's a lot of
competition between these other these
these executive branch departments some
of whom don't don't believe that the cia
should be tasked with some particular
operation or not
often even people within the cia itself
think that
thank you mr chairman i i don't really
have any questions of our esteemed
speaker
as
as one of the co-sponsors of this
legislation i i too along with many of
my colleagues here found his
his comments uh very cogent and and very
compelling but i'd like to make a couple
of comments if i if i may mr mr chairman
first of all of course all of us agree
with a couple of points that our friend
from illinois mr hyde made we've got to
improve our security
and we've got to do our very best to
find out who leaks information into and
to punish
those people but coming back to the to
the bill which is uh before us it it's
its intention basically is to carry out
the intention of the of the existing law
and if you're if you're worried about
uh leaks
then you have that exact problem of
course as as mr hyde pointed out so
livingston to a certain extent have that
exact problem under the existing law i'd
like to remind our colleagues that a
recent study by the by the intelligence
committee of the other house
found out that
147 recent occasions
of of information having been leaked
that the attributable sources in each in
in in all but 12 of those cases
was the administration or someone in the
administration rather than someone in
the congress
uh there clearly is a problem and and
the the larger problem clearly has to do
with the executive branch of of the
government for all kinds of very obvious
reasons uh the most obvious of each of
which is that there are very few
individuals both staff and members in
the senate in the house who know these
secrets
in most instances with respect to most
covert operations certainly there are
many dozens often many hundreds
sometimes thousands of people who know
these self-same secrets which some of
our colleagues are urging us to deny to
even eight of the most trusted members
of the of the uh
of the congress and there's a lot of
competition between these other these
these executive branch departments some
of whom don't don't believe that the cia
should be tasked with some particular
operation or not
often even people within the cia itself
think that
what they've been asked to do is foolish
or potentially counterproductive or
dangerous
and
if you ask
if you ask any good uh media person that
if that person told you the truth he or
she would tell you that in virtually
every instance
that person's source was someone from
the executive branch not somebody from
the from the congress of the united
states his members
of course
could the gentleman you mentioned a
study by the senate intelligence
committee that found a hundred and some
leaks came from the administration was
that right that in the in the articles
themselves the information was
attributed to someone in the executive
branch of the government who was the
chairman of that senate select and tell
me i can't remember his name but he was
a former chairman i believe okay thanks
may have even been the person that the
gentleman was speaking of earlier i'm
not
i'm not sure
as members of this committee
you know we're concerned about possible
risk of life and loss of life and so on
as members of this committee know
all of the members of this committee are
aware of certain
certain operations
that are
that are uh carried out uh that we can't
even we can't even speak of
uh
where there's continual potential uh
risk to to people's uh people's lives
let me just say one more thing if i may
mr chairman and that is that there is a
particular question which perhaps we
could speak at some some greater length
about
the hardest questions of all i guess are
those which were raised by mr hyde and
have been raised by admiral turner and
others and that's i suppose when you're
talking about hostage rescue situations
or where you're trying to save lives and
so on uh those those are situations
which tend to be short-lived uh where
there's
you can't afford any kind of of talking
about it whatsoever at the same time if
i may be frank
to at least from this member's point of
view those may be the kinds of
operations where
some of us feel that we don't really
need to know
um they're not policy they're not policy
undertakings they're not covert
operations in the larger in the larger
term
and uh and
it just seems to me that in such kinds
of cases perhaps there's no need for the
congress to know uh even under its right
to know its right to do oversight and so
on we'll eventually find out and it may
well be therefore i'm just suggesting
off the top of my head i haven't thought
this through at all that we might
perhaps
we might perhaps think of making some
exception for those kinds of
sense rescue operations i don't know as
i said as a policy matter that we that
we need to know
at least beforehand and that might solve
a lot of people's problems with the most
risky
of these of these potential kinds of of
situations
as i said that might not offend some of
us congressional leadership uh not to
find out about those things until after
they're over with or whatever so for
whatever
that may be of a useful
avenue for us to explore mr chairman
thank you thank you mr billingson mrs
cannella
thank you mr speaker uh for being with
us this morning and and thank you for
your statements i i've just i've no
questions i want to make my comments as
a new member and thank you mr speaker
for appointing me but i've found in my
life mr speaker that sometimes you say
things so often
uh they become a truism
members can't keep secrets congress
can't keep secrets uh i just look down
to my left i see people who can keep
secrets
uh because this was said so many times
it seems to me that now we have private
individuals uh retired military and uh
members unelected officials and
lieutenant colonels running uh many
things
uh i appreciate you being here because
it shows the support you have for this
committee
for the oversight
charge of this congress
mr chairman do you think individual
congressmen can and women can keep
secrets
women of course
surely congressmen and congresswomen can
keep secrets perhaps some of us cannot
we're i don't know where we're we're
like people
but those who cannot keep secrets have
no business on this committee
thank you mr speaker that that's what i
would like to hear you say because as a
new member on the committee i think i'm
in a very wonderful position of a new
beginning and hopefully this bill will
be the new beginning we went full circle
that the fact was that nobody could keep
a secret so those that weren't even
elected were given the charge of doing
things because we couldn't keep the
secret so i i thank you for coming and
putting your support behind this bill
because hopefully the
oversight charge of the congress now
we'll go back to the seriousness in the
place that maybe it should have been
and it takes a crisis often like the
iran confirmation to bring these things
into being so i thank you for taking all
this time to be with us and thank you i
think hopefully
you're joining here prove that maybe we
can have to prove that we can keep it
secret
mr speaker we all appreciate you thank
you very much chairman thank you
our next witness is uh the distinguished
minority leader of the house of
representatives robert michael of
illinois
mr michael like
the speaker before him
has been
an ex-official member of the
intelligence committee
and has added considerably to our
deliberations and functions and we're
very grateful
mr michael for your presence here this
morning well thank you mr chairman and
my colleagues on the committee
um
as you indicated i've been very
privileged to serve as an ex-official
member of the committee my only regret
is that because of our
duties otherwise we're limited in our
attendance but i'd like to address
myself if i might to the bill h.r 1013
introduced by the chairman
which would amend the national security
act of 1947 and section 662 of the
foreign assistance act of 61 the highest
the hughes ryan amendment when the
chairman introduced
his bill on february 4th of this year he
said and i think it's bearing
bears well to have it repeated here with
these amendments the scheme for covert
action reporting will be quite clear
first in almost all cases prior notice
must be given to the intelligence
committees second in rare cases where
the president believes there's an
unusual degree of sensitivity prior
notice must be given but it may be given
to the leadership group set out in
section 501 and third in even rarer
cases where the president must react
with speed because of an immediate
threat to our national security notice
may be deferred for a maximum
a maximum of 48 hours
now i'm not a constitutional scholar
but i've been in the member of the
congress for 30 years i've seen the
legislative branch and the executive
branch come to loggerheads on
constitutional prerogatives over and
over again but nowhere
has the issue
been more forcefully joined in the
language of the amendment i've just read
and nowhere has the issue been more
serious
what we're dealing with here is a
fundamental question of foreign policy
if i may judge from the remarks made by
the chairman during that same floor
speech in february his amendment has its
origins and the controversy surrounding
the iran contra arms affair in the
notification issue
i'll not comment on the facts of the
iran contra affair because we already
have two congressional committees
working full-time to cover those facts
and while i've read with interest
varying interpretations of the
president's decision not to notify
congress my appearance here today is not
concerned with the legal and historical
questions of that issue i'd rather talk
about the future than the past about the
dangers i see to our nation if the
chairman's amendment never becomes law
legislation proposed in the heat of
political passion
with long-range questions of national
security
overshadowed by short-term responses to
current controversies is not congress
acting at its best and i fully
understand the motivation that led to
this proposed legislation i understand
the frustration that supporters of the
legislation might feel given their
perception of the events surrounding the
iran contra affair but a sense of
frustration
justified or unjustified is not a
sufficient cause to create legislation
like this and in dealing with
intelligence oversight the congress has
never intended to confront an american
president with language that is the
functional equivalent of a foreign
policy straight jacket
there's an old rule of thumb about
problem solving it says that we should
never try to seek more accuracy in our
answers than the facts of the question
permit
in short we should never sacrifice the
good to the bad to the best we should
never try to find a perfect formula for
states of affairs that do not by their
very nature allow perfection
jay no this cut this 200th anniversary
of our congress and uh last weekend
again i was reminded of how valuable it
is every once in a while to look back to
the constitution itself the preamble and
to and to regenerate ourselves by the
roots by which we're all here today
james madison in the federalist paper
number 48 described the possibility of
the legislative branch encroaching on
the legitimate functions of the other
branches speaking of the legislative
branch he wrote quote its constitutional
powers being at once more extensive
and less susceptible of precise limits
it can with greater facility mask under
complicated and indirect measures the
encroachments which it makes on the
coordinate departments to put the matter
in less in the less eloquent but perhaps
more emphatic language of our own time
congress can pass legislation whose
stated aim is doing good for all
concerned but whose effect will be
encroachment on the rights of other of
the other branches of government the
constitution of the united states made
it clear from the beginning that there
could be no clear-cut easy answer
ready-made formulation to do away with
the inherent tension between two
branches of government each with
legitimate powers they knew that
sometimes we would have to live in the
gray fog shrouded area of the political
landscape between the executive and the
legislative powers where clarity isn't
always possible now if you feel mr
chairman as you said in your statement
that the bond of mutual respect respect
between the committee and the cia has
been broken
the worst way to re-establish that old
bond of trust is by forging new chains
of legislative language we should not
fool ourselves that we can solve these
complex problems simply by writing new
language i wish it were that simple but
it's not
under a system of government like ours
we have to take risks
democracy itself is a risk and there are
no guarantees but one risk we cannot
take we can't risk having our
adversaries and indeed our friends
perceive an american president as not
being able to move quickly and
decisively
because congress has restricted his
flexibility
i stress the word perceive
there are learned counselors and expert
witnesses on both sides of this issue
we who are not constitutional lawyers or
experts can only listen and try to make
some very humble judgments but whatever
the constitutional issues involved if
this legislation became law the
perception
of a weakened presidency would be
universal no amount of convoluted
arguments about what the legislation
means could erase the impression that
the congress intends to limit a
president's flexibility
this may not be your intention but it'll
be the perception
and in politics including geopolitics
perception is all important and i can
think of no worse scenario than one in
which a soviet leader meets with an
american president any american
president
in the future
believing that our president has been
stripped of the freedom to act swiftly
and with flexibility
again i don't question the motivation
behind the proposal what i question is
the wisdom of congress acting in the
emotion of this iran contra affair
placing restrictions upon the very
institution of the presidency itself
restrictions that are in my view
constitutionally dubious and
strategically dangerous let me turn for
a moment to another aspect of the issue
it may seem peripheral but i believe
it's important in the overall context of
the debate over congressional oversight
there are those who say no
administration can afford to trust the
congress with secret information for
fear it will be leaked
the tower commission report addressed
this point among its recommendations
what the report had to say about the
problem of possible leaks is worth
quoting in full
from the tower commission there is a
natural tension between the desire for
secrecy and the need to consult congress
on covert operations presidents seem to
become increasingly concerned about
leaks of classified information as their
administration progress they blame
congress disproportionately various
cabinet officials from prior
administrations indicated to the board
that they believe congress bears no more
blame than the executive branch and i
would surely have to underscore that
however the numbers of members and staff
involved in the re reviewing covert
activities is large
it provides cause for concern and a
convenient excuse for presidents to
avoid congressional consultation
tower commission still quoting here we
recommend that congress consider
replacing the existing intelligence
committees of their respective houses
with a joint new joint committee with a
restricted staff to oversee the
intelligence community pattern after the
joint committee on atomic energy that
existed until the mid 1970s
i'm glad to see that the tower
commission did not engage in congress
bashing when it came to discussing leaks
of classified information but it's worth
repeating that the report did say the
number of members and staff involved in
reviewing covert activities is large
it provides cause for concern
i think that it is very fair and
accurate assessment of the situation our
distinguished colleague mr hyde has
proposed legislation that there be one
joint congressional intelligence
committee proposal i support i think
that we should embrace mr hyde's
proposal since it reflects the concerns
of many including the members of the
tower commission in conclusion my re my
view is that
intelligence oversight can work
as it has in the past
when there is the give and take of
debate
uh the freedom for a present to maneuver
along with the acknowledgement indeed as
well as word of the legitimate right of
congress to be properly informed in
order to perform its oversight functions
and i think the legislation we already
have on the books reflects a wise
prudent compromise to a complex problem
the legislation frankly ain't broke so
let's not attempt to fix it
now
very briefly
on that 48-hour
limitation
you know i'm thinking of uh
of the difficulty involved there if
we're depending upon
who those members are that we want to be
notifying and how many
uh congress is away on weekends all so
frequently and then when we're on break
whether it's uh
lincoln's birthday or memorial day or
the fourth of july or uh in august or
whenever the congress adjourns and we're
spread to the four winds all around the
globe
and you're gonna require within 48 hours
notification
of individual members on a secure basis
you know we could be in
timbuktu where even today we're
recognizing in the soviet union we got a
real serious problem for the secretary
of state communicating back to his
government
now that has got to be a a very serious
uh a problem for us
uh and then the very fact of all it's
developed by way of inner you know
intelligent communication intercepts
you know we yes i've tried to be very
very careful about some of the sensitive
information that i've received to make
absolutely sure that i'm on some
secure line
but how you know how accessible
accessible are those secure lines to
those of us who may not be in right in
our offices where the facilities are
right there for us
to use
and then finally i noticed you know in
in the deletion of part of the existing
law there
uh that provision which has to do
specifically mr chairman with other than
activities intended solely for obtaining
necessary intelligence
not even an exception for intelligence
gathering
now
let's suppose we've got an agent or a
couple or whatever
someplace abroad
and the president says now
we'd like to plant a
plant a seed
someplace if you're given the
opportunity
now uh
i'm not altogether sure under the
language of the of the chairman's uh
bill here whether or not
the president at that point is supposed
to be advising members of congress that
hey i've this is what i have uh
uh what i'm proposing out there
and uh
you know when is the time the the agent
may be
behind a screen
that we know all were all too familiar
with today
he's given a commission
to do a certain thing prospectively
depending upon what some other act may
take place out there
and certainly within the president's
right in maintaining the security of our
country to have that
that tentacle out there and those eyes
and ears out there to do certain things
for intelligence gathering
i just don't see you know when you wipe
out that that exception again in your
legislation
we've got a problem
i'm reminded in
this growing controversy here you know i
i remember
and not no reflection at all upon our
own individual members of congress with
respect to you know
how we're given to leaking information
but i can remember several speakers of
the past who refrain from appointing
certain members of the house of
representatives to certain committees
because of those speakers doubts about
those members
abilities whatever to serve on those
committees
now they have may very well when we take
the oath of office
support and defend the constitution
but i'll tell you there's nothing in
that oath
under those circumstances that
forecloses possible leaks of very
sensitive information
and
then
this issue of covert versus overt
operations
i dare say there are some members of the
house of representatives of the congress
who frankly have a personal bias against
covert operations period
i happen to think they're absolutely
essential even in a free society
and in my own responsibilities leader
would never ever appoint a member to
this committee
who frankly had that personal bias
against covert operation because i don't
think that would serve the serve the the
system well or the house of
representatives well so those are the
thoughts i had be happy to subject
myself to questions apologize for the
lengthy well thank you very much uh mr
michael for your
for your statement uh
first i think it's important uh
to stress as you did that we should look
at this issue dispassionately and not in
any sense of frustration and i hope
that's the manner in which the committee
will proceed
secondly i think it is important to
distinguish between collection of
intelligence on the one hand
and covert operations on the other and i
think that this bill clearly
is directed to covert operations
i would point out that in president
reagan's executive order of december
1981
he defined covert operations as those
quote conducted in support of national
foreign policy objectives abroad which
are planned and executed so that the
role of the united states is not
approved or acknowledged publicly but
which are not intended to influence u.s
political processes public opinion
policies or media and this is the part
that's important and do not include
diplomatic activities or the collection
and production of intelligence or
related support functions so covert
covert operations to which this bill is
directed does not cover the collection
of intelligence which we all agree
uh should not be subject to prior
notification uh to congress
i would
ask you about the iran you know i think
that if this perchance this legislation
then should get to the house floor
and uh then in the uh
in the legislative history i think that
would be a very very important point
that would have to be aerated and
discussed because as i said you know the
the language deleted
automatically wipes out that exception
that we
at this day have in the law specifically
well i don't think that's correct but in
any event we can certainly make clear in
legislative history that we're not
intending to influence or affect uh
collection of intelligence
uh you you indicated that you'd like to
look forward in terms of uh
in terms of this proposal and its impact
and i think that's an important thing
for us to do but it's not irrelevant to
consider the iran
uh arms transaction because that's a
real life case i understand and from the
perspective of some of us it reflects
not just what happened in that
particular instance but it reflects what
we perceive to be an attitude of this
particular administration with respect
to congressional oversight generally
now we may be wrong about that but
nonetheless the perception is there
and as others will i'm sure testify
there is an argument that you shouldn't
try to write something into law
to cover congressional oversight and
notification but rather it should be
based upon trust and comedy and i agree
with that so long as the trust and
comedy exists
but as the iran case demonstrates
at least to some of us
there is a perception in the
administration on the part of some that
congress can't be trusted or it's an
inconvenience or obstacle rather than a
help
and
i would ask you with respect to the iran
arms case whether or not in your
judgment the president complied with
existing law
which requires in the case where prior
notice is not given
that the president shall notify the
intelligence committees in a timely
fashion the president signed his
uh finding authorizing this operation on
january seventeenth nineteen eighty six
we did not learn of this at any time
from the white house or from anyone else
in the administration as mr casten meyer
had said earlier we learned about it
because it was disclosed in a middle
east magazine
well does that comply with existing law
never mind the proposal which is being
made here today well let me say that i
personally am very succinctly personally
offended
by the fact that
i was left out of the loop for so long
and
i'm certainly not going to apologize
for my own administration
for having taken that tack
because
as you indicate
there are those of us who know how to
keep a secret can be trusted
with this country's security
and uh there is an obligation for a
shared role and responsibility between
the executive and legislative and so uh
but what i'm saying
i'm not altogether sure the system
you know is wrong
some of the individuals involved
uh uh
more victims of their own individual
body chemistry and what they what their
feelings were i guess
vis-a-vis
an executive branch versus legislating
and so um
i i have a real reluctance
to put that kind of uh to put some kind
of a
straight jacket on some future president
i'd like to think no matter who he or
she may be
and those around them that they will
have learned
certainly from this experience that
that was not
not the appropriate way in which to
to conduct that operation shirley i
presume uh mr michael that if the
president had
notified you of his plans to sell arms
to iran covertly
that you would have expressed some
reservation or objection to that well i
think there would certainly have been
those of us who would have reminded
whomever at that time
of some of the other commitments that
were made to us for which we went out on
the line
as a matter of principle with respect to
our absolute
uh prohibition
of dealing with terrorists period you
know and uh
i i must
confess that i had a very hard time to
assimilate what what had gone on but
don't you think don't you think the iran
case in this connection is a good
example of why prior notification in
most cases
is a benefit to the president as well as
a right of the congress
well
i i know we've
we've left this rather ambiguous in the
past by way of
timely notification
and we've argued that point you know on
the floor of the house any number of
times
and it's going to be open to various
interpretations depending upon who the
individual is i guess
and i i would just i just very reluctant
to deny a president of the future that
kind of flexibility trusting
hopefully that
whoever he or she might be will have
learned from this experience that that
was not in the spirit of the law
to have that long a gap between the act
and the notification of those of us who
i think deserved some heads up on what
was going on because those of us who are
in the really actively on that political
cutting edge out there on a day-to-day
basis
do have some good in
some good things to volunteer once in a
while thank you very much mr livingston
thank you mr chairman mr michael i want
to commend you on an outstanding
statement i want to thank you for your
input
and i just want to concentrate on excuse
me on your point
about
the amendment to section b of existing
law
in reading that specific exception the
words other than activities intended
solely for obtaining necessary
intelligence
would be struck
as you have
eloquently pointed out
which would require that even the most
mundane
obtaining of necessary intelligence and
all of the covert activities inherent in
that activity
would be required to be shared by the
president and the executive department
with
various members of congress
and in most cases in advance
rather than uh
48 hours after the fact
is that your understanding and do you uh
well that's the way i uh i i was i
always considered this to be a very
important exception that we had
currently uh
you know written into the law and that
when we're about to wipe out a very
important exception then i have to ask
why
what's the reason for it i totally agree
with you
even if it were the most significant
intelligence gathering uh
uh
activities it would seem that this is
not the type of thing that should be
shared
and and could very well totally close
down our our capability to gather
intelligence around the world well and i
must say you know i'm not the specialist
here i see we got a couple of us behind
us here stanfield turner and bill colby
and there may be others that can
probably speak more directly to that but
from this legislator's point of view i i
have a real problem with it well i thank
you for your statement thank you i have
no further questions
thank you mr stokes
thank you mr chairman and
let me also uh commend our distinguished
minority leader for his appearance here
this morning and
the excellent statement he's given
in support of his views
on the
statement that you made with reference
to putting the president a foreign
policy straight jacket
as the distinguished minority leader
knows
the law already requires
timely notice to the congress so we're
not saying that the president has to do
something he's not already required to
do under law
does the distinguished minority leader
by any stretch of the imagination
say to us that
notice after 14 months if we take
mcfarland's testimony in the public
domain where he said it was august of 85
when the president first gave approval
for the sale of the arms by the israelis
to iran by any stretch of imagination
would distinguish the leaders say that
was timely notice to the country oh that
was not right
um
and i can say to you that in crafting
this legislation i don't think either i
or
ed
or
the distinguished former chairman of
this committee uh one of the most
distinguished members of the house and
gentleman who
distinguished himself by chairing this
committee for six years who was a
co-sponsor this legislation
intends in any way
to tie the president's hands we respect
the fact the president has to make
certain exigent decisions and must have
latitude for that
but ed bolden has stated on several
occasions that when they entered into
the original language on timely notice
that it was based upon mutual trust
between the congress and the president
and it seems to me here now that
you would probably agree with me
that we're confronted with a situation
where because the president made a
unilateral decision on his part without
the involvement of the congress
we are now in a situation where the
president himself as a consequence of
this act
has requested an independent prosecutor
to conduct a criminal investigation of
this act
he has requested both houses of the
congress to investigate the consequences
of his act
and i think
that the distinguished minority leader
would agree with me that
had he complied with the law
let's say
timely notice being somewhere within a
48-hour period
or if the current if the law i propose
had been
uh enacted say 48 hours and he had come
over to the congress and said to our
committee which you have sat on for now
10 years that he planned to do what he
planned to do
isn't it conceivable
that
some of us on that committee would have
had enough common sense to say to him mr
president
this is bad go back to the drawing board
and think about this one again mr
president don't you think that that
would have happened
well i'm not altogether sure it would
have been the president himself who
would have come up but at least
someone personally responsible uh
speaking in his behalf
and that
there would have been a obviously
significant reaction on our part i think
maybe from both sides of the aisle
and varying in degree but uh
um
i i as i said and indicated i that's
that that timely fashion is open to
interpretation from my point of view as
i said i felt offended that it took that
long before you know we were to now
bearing in mind i guess
it
it is
it was an operation that was somewhat
far removed from the kind of
normal things we think of here
this whole hostage
issue is one
in more recent years that's come to the
fore that we guessed
a number of years ago when i first came
to the congress i don't think we're
anybody was given any serious thought to
what the problem might be for us with
respect to the hostage issue but in more
recent years ever since the the carter
administration and this one we've been
caught up in this thing and yes i guess
new developments probably require a
reassessment of how we deal with that
and i'm not altogether sure we've found
out how to deal with it yet but that was
part of
i think the reason for uh
for the lengthy delay and notification
because it took so long through
intermediates to get the kind of
contacts
that eventually were supposed to bear
fruit but i
as i said i'm i'm troubled by that long
delay
thank you chairman
mr hyde thank you mr chairman i want to
congratulate you
mr michael for a superb statement and
analysis of a very thorny problem and i
want to associate myself with your
sharp criticism of the administration in
not timely notifying congress
the law is clear and 14 months is not
timely and i think the law in that sense
was not observed and i think that the
administration is paying a political
price for that as every administration
will when they do not observe the letter
or the spirit of the law and i would
personally like to see timely fashion
stay in there and we will define timely
fashion as we're doing now by saying
this surely wasn't and the
administration is paying a price for
that
but
in addition by notifying congress you
get some risk insurance when
something is high risk and and and
doesn't go right but that said and and i
firmly believe that and i agree with
with the spirit of of this legislation
but i sure don't agree with
how it handles it
you all except mrs canelli was not on
the committee remember perfectly well
when the secretary of state
came into our committee and told us of a
very
sensitive operation and those were his
words
and the next day
it was in the washington post in detail
and there are people who say some lives
a life was lost
probably lost on that disclosure now
i can understand the white house and mr
casey uh
concerned that the leaks come from his
own agency from the state department
from capitol hill where we are besieged
by media after every meeting just for
background just without for attribution
confirm what i've heard from somewhere
else and i can understand a a paranoia
if you can say there's such thing as a
legitimate paranoia the leaks are legion
and and i have so many of them here and
i don't like to talk about them because
you you give some legitimacy to to the
disclosure but
the 48 hours is just hog tying a
president
in in matters where we ought to leave it
at timely notice and if they don't
observe it
force the that political price to be
paid two more things
we're besieged by spy
scandals the campilis case where this
employee sold them a manual about a
secret
very highly sensitive satellite the
morrison case the pollard case the
howard case the walker case the three
marines etc etc and we're spending our
energy
trying to disseminate more classified
information instead of trying to address
at least in tandem with our concerns
about notification some of these serious
problems
permit me to digress to answer something
that the speaker said that really
deserves an answer in all fairness he
assailed the cia
for conduct on two matters one of which
was chile and i just want to indulge
the chairman by reading one to two
paragraphs from a book written by mr
colby that is an excellent book
on the cia honorable men my life in the
cia by william colby and he discusses
that
chilean
myth that has we have heard for time
immemorial how dirty the cia was and how
we overthrew this democratically elected
leftist alien day night let me quote
from page 305 two points need to be made
about cia's assistance during this
period after 1970 and both are a
contrast to the general impressions
abroad about it the first is that cia's
help was to center political groups not
the right wing extremists of the
millions of dollars spent in chile by
cia the most prominent right-wing group
patria e libertad received some 38 000
during the track 2 effort in 1970 about
7 000 more during 71 and none thereafter
the second is that this 1973 coup
was carried out by the chilean military
with no participation by cia in fact cia
sent clear instructions to its station
in santiago in may and june 73 to
separate itself from any contact with
the chilean military so that it would
not be misunderstood to have been
involved in any coup action the military
might undertake the real thrust of cia's
program was to support the center
political forces so they could win the
next elections and thus remove allende
through peaceful means now i say that
because i didn't want to interrupt the
speaker while he was here but this is
going out over c-span and i think the
record ought to be clear
that the cia
performed
adequately
in chile they made mistakes being human
but they are not to be assigned guilt
for overthrowing the great democrat
allende because they didn't and i thank
the chairman for that time
mr castenwar
thank you mr chairman
glad to greet the minority leader here
i am on the point of 48 hours i would
think that the committee would want to
look at the timing in terms of whether
48 hours is some
peculiar
validity as a time frame or something
else
i do
and i think that and other issues were
appropriately raised
by mr michael
i do take issue with him with the
implication that somehow
those appointed to the committee should
be
predisposed to support covert action
i
i think that that
that is a basic fundamental difference i
perhaps have with the gentleman from
illinois
there are many who feel in the agency
and
and others that
that frankly in terms of the agency that
that covert action has been sort of the
bane the thing that has
damaged the agency over the
years granted there have been effective
useful covert action programs
in historically and there have been some
that have been an embarrassment to this
country
therefore
i would suggest and furthermore the
intelligence committee is concerned
with intelligence gathering and analysis
much of it highly technical in terms of
let's say
96 98
of our budget and of our efforts are and
intelligence intelligence gathering the
covert action is the small portion
and i would think this is where we need
critical review that is a sort of
dispassionate
view second guess if you will on the
part of the congress
and that should not imply as the
gentleman from illinois my friend mr
hyde suggests that those who might
oppose given certain given initiatives
are disposed to leak those initiatives i
don't think the connection is there
for
if i am disposed to oppose a program
i feel i must be purer than caesar's
wife
on that with respect
to possibly suggesting
or leaking anything about it
uh what the gentleman yes of course i
thank the gentleman and i hope i did not
imply that opposition predisposed
someone to leaking i surely don't
believe that at all i simply say there
are isolated instances where people
really think it's a higher duty
uh to uh to leak a a program or a policy
if they're against it and i quoted one
former member whom we all knew and
admired
as that was his his duty to to leak a
program and there are others who feel
that way and we know who they are
that was a member of another committee
but i i accept the speaker's premise
that those who are appointed to this
committee above all
are are absolutely bound to confidence
whether we whether we like activities
whether we support them or not
and
i i hope that we can be effective in in
in
ensuring that the competence in the
committee is justified by the house
thank you mr chairman mr billingson
thank you thank you mr chairman i i too
as as all of us is
enjoyed having our our good friend from
from illinois uh
mr mr michael here with us today he's
made some very useful points and among
them again it's interesting how you just
listen to testimony and things crop up
that might that are useful uh the point
he made with
the gentleman made with respect to where
where one of these eight folks might be
when time for notification came around
that's something perhaps mr chairman we
should take a look at
we might for example limit it to uh to
require the notification only when
those those of the amongst those eight
members or however many were speaking of
are in the country or even in washington
dc and can be notified personally uh
certainly not perhaps when they're
overseas
there might possibly be someone else you
should notify in their stead if they are
not easily accessible or or they don't
have clear access to a secure line or
something because i think the gentleman
brings up some very valid points there
are
speaker might take some of his friends
maybe even his friend from illinois
overseas sometime and and the last thing
we'd want is the is the president
calling them up
when they're in the soviet union let's
say a month from now and trying to
inform them about something that soviet
union shouldn't know about so that's uh
perhaps we can we could draft that
portion of the of the bill a little bit
uh
more more more carefully tony if i may
make one further observation that also
came to mind
let's face it our adversaries know
who the members are on this committee
and they know who the leaders are
and when uh
at
one given time
all these members are given a
simultaneous notification of something
is up
if you don't believe that in itself
is a key and a tip-off to your adversary
then you know that that that's another
uh
element in this thing and uh
i i just wan i just from a point of
being extraordinarily careful about what
how we tip our hand that that ought to
also be taken into account
thank you let me let me go on if i may
for a moment mr chairman just to respond
to a couple of things that that our
friend mr michael said if you if you if
you believe as i believe and i think you
use the word uh
mr michael that legislation on the books
that we have now is is wise legislation
um you know then one would have to ask
what what's wrong with spelling out the
requirements a little bit more because
as you and mr hyde and everybody quite
naturally and quite properly i think
feel that that the the timely notice
requirements didn't work in this
particular case then perhaps 48 hours as
others have suggested it isn't isn't the
cure all but somehow
somehow what we've got now is not quite
adequate although we all believe that
it's a it's wise legislation in general
so let's struggle together perhaps to
find some way of of defining that a
little bit further
of course you're very kind and indulgent
uh
the law wasn't inadequate the
observation of the law was inadequate
but every time the law isn't obeyed we
don't need to change the law we need
better uh observance of the law and i
think
i think these hearings are moving us in
that direction but i
i when you start putting time with time
limits on it it gets to be
micromanagement and in effect frankly
for her for henry and myself it's a bit
embarrassing because we understand that
you know that
did not do what we would have thought
they should have been doing but even
with that you see i think we would take
the strong position not knowing who
ongoing presidents might be that we want
to be very careful but what do you do
you want to lay down some guidelines if
possible that are quite explicit as to
what exactly is required of them uh they
can argue about the timeliness thing
they couldn't argue about the 48 hours
and so therefore i'm just we're
suggesting that we come up with
something that's that's relatively
unarguable it's not enough to hope as
our friend from illinois uh suggested
that some future administrations will
remember or will have will have learned
because in fact
we learned through history that people
forget and in fact the folks who are
carrying out the policy in a particular
administration may be in their 30s or
their 40s and not even been around or at
least as as grown-ups or people who are
aware of what was happening at the time
of the next of the next crisis i mean
you go back home and talk to folks about
about the second world war they don't
even know there was a second world war i
mean you go back and talk to the kids in
high school they weren't even around
when the vietnam war was here so these
things
these things don't teach lessons to to
those who are coming along you've got to
keep reminding people and to the extent
that you can usefully put something in
legislation uh you should do so again
bob mr michael with respect to a weekend
presidency i don't think anybody here is
suggesting that we strip the president
of of
his ability to act in any respect we are
trying to require again as as you know
trying to concentrate on his on our
right to be informed as a coordinate who
equal branch of the of the government
and finally mr mr hyde as as he often
does and has several times here today
makes a useful point just for
for the public's interests and
consumption that
in in
in speaking about espionage cases which
have been very much with us recently in
the last few years those in fact are
cases which are far more dangerous
far more costly
far more destructive and damaging to our
national interests probably than any of
the things we're talking about
and that's something people should keep
in mind we're talking not about those
sorts of things or even intelligence
gathering as we got off on a little bit
ago we're talking really i think about
policy matters and about covert actions
and part of the problem again frankly
and i'll i'll then stop mr chairman
because it probably exceeded my my five
minutes part of the problem one must say
frankly is that that the main foreign
policy initiatives of this particular
administration the so-called reagan
doctrine are initiatives which are
designed in such ways uh supposedly
covert although in fact everybody knows
about them which are often funded or
done through the intelligence committees
which cannot be openly debated on the
floor and it leaves us all in a very
difficult situation
you know we
the congress has to be part of all of
this in one respect or another but we
can't play our ordinary role of debating
it on the floor talking about how much
money we're spending because it's all
been it's all been given to us in this
other form of covert action you know not
not because i think the president wants
to or the administration wants to avoid
this kind of debate but because he
believes in these kinds of covert
actions but
but it it
makes it difficult for us because we
have a part to play and it's difficult
for us to play that part because we're
not allowed to talk about any of these
things even though they're in the papers
all the time and everybody else knows
about them but we can't talk about them
so we never know what to say or not to
say and not knowing what more to say mr
chairman will be happy
thank you mr billingson mrs cannella
thank you uh mr michael i'm just curious
i know i know some of the things that
are set up for the speaker since he's
the third line
under the constitution to be president
but are you from your remarks are you
satisfied as the statute is written now
that you could be adequately notified
that at all times contact could be got
with you is that mechanism set up
presently under the under the statute as
is written now
well i think there has to be a certain
measure of trust
and
when the american people and of course
we're in that time when both parties are
picking candidates to run for president
and there's a long long tortures trail
to that end of the line
but i think after one comes through all
that you know we have to give a certain
measure of trust and confidence to
whomever the american people at that
time have chosen to be their
commander-in-chief and
and i have to trust to that judgment of
the people from time to time may be
against my best wishes but uh i i think
and misunderstood mr michael since we do
live in a time of possible terrorism
within this country which is is
considerable possibility are you always
available
to know where you are does the white
house know where you are
well i don't know that they've had any
real
problem ever running
running me down personally uh
we
they knew where you were
excuse me they knew where you were on
the override
oh yes
and i make a special point of letting
them know i think where we're going to
be at at any given time
uh mr michael you satisfied this
committee can could contact you
if in fact this legislation passed with
the 48 hours well of course
there may be some times
you know
might be inaccessible for a some limited
period of time but uh but i tell you
it's i guess my concern is
when you're doing it simultaneously the
signal that's tipped on that because
that can be that can be people can be
aware of that simultaneous notification
there are ways and means by which that
that is determined
and then to uh the further away from
this capital city of washington you are
the more
[Music]
uh the more of a problem that becomes
thank you mr white
yes one more question in the witness
very briefly yes mr hyde go ahead what
do you do mr michael when a another
country that you're dealing with in
tandem on an operation conditions their
participation
on non-disclosure they've got their
citizens involved their agents their
people and they they read the papers and
they will they'll help you and they we
may desperately need their help but they
condition their participation on
non-disclosure what do you do then if
you're trapped into a 48-hour
uh uh that's the unanswerable question
it's a good one to put i could have put
it the same way but i think it uh the
very raising of the question by the
distinguished gentleman um you know begs
some kind of answer from the committee
eventually when it makes its final
decision thank you chairman
thank you very much mr michael before
excusing you finally i just want to
reassure you again on the question of
whether or not
what we're doing here or proposing here
would affect the collection of
intelligence and i would point out that
section 662 of the foreign assistance
act which is the the use ryan amendment
which is still in effect and would be
after this bill were enacted
clearly provides that covert operations
and the notice requirements are not
intended to affect intelligence
gathering so i think your understandable
concern about that would would be uh
would be taken care of uh by this
particular language one question mr
stokes just one question of the
distinguishment already before he leaves
since uh he agrees that 14 months is not
timely
notification under the statute
and since he feels that 48 hours
severely
constricts the president
does the gentleman care to offer a time
limit that he's agreeable too
[Laughter]
well i i could tell by the the
gentleman's demeanor that he was about
to pop that question
and i guess i just have to say it must
be someplace in between
but where i would as i said i have a
real problem when we get to finally
delineating and specifically tying that
down that's a difficult one to call
thank you but i think that more than
anything
to really i think the committee has been
made aware of the real serious problem
or is in that type
of frame i'll leave it go with that
thank you very thank you thank you very
much mr michael we appreciate you being
here our next schedule witnessed was to
be senator moynihan of new york but he
is the floor leader
on the question of the highway bill
override in the senate and so he uh he
has submitted his statement and will not
be with us
uh there is
one comment in his statement which i
would without objection uh like to read
at this point because it gets to the
heart of the question of whether
congress can be trusted and i think mr
hyatt has suggested that in certain
cases the intelligence community should
be able to
not be burdened with telling congress
mr moynihan says there's a notion that
the congress cannot be trusted
not be burdened with telling congress
mr moynihan says there's a notion that
the congress cannot be trusted that the
congress is national security risk
wrong
committees here take matters with great
care
you treat matters before your committee
with that the congress is national
security risk
wrong
committees here take matters with great
care you treat matters before your
committee with great care we're not to
be held responsible for the revelation
of public belligerent acts such as the
mining of nicaraguan harbors or
revelations by adverse great care we're
not to be held responsible for the
revelation of public belligerent acts
such as the mining of nicaraguan harbors
or revelations by adversaries such as
happened in the beirut newspaper
al-shura
when you get to the point where you
trust her garbonifar a man the career
intelligence service did not trust aries
such as happened in the beirut newspaper
al-shura
when you get to the point where you
trust or garbonifar a man the career
intelligence service did not trust
before you trust the speaker of the
house or when you decide to pass on
intelligence information to the
ayatollah but will not inform the
chairman of the intelligence committee
before you trust the speaker of the
house or when you decide to pass on
intelligence information to the
ayatollah but will not inform the
chairman of the intelligence committee
of a presidential finding that matters
are confused and it's time to add some
order with amendments such as these
unquote
we have a presidential finding that
matters are confused and it's time to
add some order with amendments such as
these unquote
i would like to invite our next
witnesses to
join us in a panel in an effort to save
their time and ours
and with apologies for i would like to
invite our next witnesses to
join us in a panel in an effort to save
their time and ours
and with apologies for the length of our
prior discussion our witnesses have been
very patient and we're very grateful for
their
patience as well as their presence here
today
the length of our prior discussion our
witnesses have been very patient and
we're very grateful for their
patience as well as their presence here
today
uh our first
panelist will be admiral stansfield
turner
who as everyone knows served as director
of the central and uh our first
panelist will be admiral stansfield
turner
who as everyone knows served as director
of the central intelligence agency
during the carter administration
graduated from the naval academy in 1946
spent two years at oxford as a rhodes
scholar his intelligence agency during
the carter administration
graduated from the naval academy in 1946
spent two years at oxford as a rhodes
scholar his naval service included two
years as president of the naval war
college and two years as commander of
the nato southern command
our second panelist will be civil
service included two years as president
of the naval war college and two years
as commander of the nato southern
command
our second panelist will be mr william
colby
who also served as director of central
intelligence and had a very long and
distinguished career in the intelligence
business before that mr william colby
who also served as director of central
intelligence and had a very long and
distinguished career in the intelligence
business before that he's appeared
before our committee as admiral turner
has many times and they've always
contributed significantly to our
discussion that
he's appeared before our committee as
admiral turner has many times and
they've always contributed significantly
to our discussion our third panelist
will be ray klein dr klein is presently
chairman of the u.s global strategy
council and as an adjunct professor our
third panelist will be ray klein
dr klein is presently chairman of the
u.s global strategy council and is an
adjunct professor of international law
at georgetown university school of
foreign service he's previously served
as a deputy director for intelligence at
the cia
director of international law at
georgetown university school of foreign
service he's previously served as a
deputy director for intelligence at the
cia director of the bureau of
intelligence and research at the
department of state and is a senior
advisor at the center for strategic and
international studies
we appreciate all of you being here the
bureau of intelligence and research at
the department of state and as a senior
advisor at the center for strategic and
international studies
we appreciate all of you being here and
admiral turner if we may start with you
please
thank you mr chairman and
viewer the time i've
sat there and current admiral turner if
we may start with you please
thank you mr chairman and
view of the time i've
sat here and cut my presentation in half
you i believe have a written copy of it
as well as a classified addendum to it
so without objection we'll include that
in the record let me just uh hit the
hype my presentation in half you i
believe have a written copy of it as
well as a classified addendum to it so
without objection we'll include that in
the record let me just hit the
highlights of it as quickly as i can for
you sir
with one exception which i will note
below
i believe it's very delights of it as
quickly as i can for you sir
with one exception which i will note
below
i believe it's very desirable that the
intelligence oversight committees of the
congress
be informed of all covert activities
within the 48-hour limit proposed by the
bill desirable that the intelligence
oversight committees of the congress
be informed of all covert activities
within the 48-hour limit proposed by the
bill
the question is
is this provision of law the best way to
ensure that the congress will in fact be
informed within 48 hours of the signing
the question is is this provision of law
the best way to ensure that the congress
will in fact be informed within 48 hours
of the signing of a covert action
finding by the president
we've recently had an unfortunate
example of the finding of january 17
1986 of a covert action finding by the
president
we've recently had an unfortunate
example of the finding of january 17
1986
regarding cia's support and facilitating
the delivery of arms to iran
the fact that notification was not
gimmicks regarding cia support in
facilitating the delivery of arms to
iran
the fact the notification was not given
to congress of that finding stands
starkly in contrast with a written
agreement made between the director of
central intelligence and the senate into
congress of that finding stan starkly in
contrast with a written agreement made
between the director of central
intelligence and the senate select
committee on intelligence
in the spring of nineteen eighty four
in the wake of the controversy
over weather select committee on
intelligence
in the spring of 1984
in the wake of the controversy
over whether the congress was adequately
informed about the mining of the
nicaraguan harbors the director of
central intelligence purportedly pledged
that congress was adequately informed
about the mining of the nicaraguan
harbors
the director of central intelligence
purportedly pledged
in a written document that had the
approval of the president
to ensure that the congress was informed
in the future of all significant
intelligence activity in a written
document that had the approval of the
president
to ensure that the congress was informed
in the future of all significant
intelligence activities
it would appear reasonable to consider
that the cia's support for the sale of
arms to iran was a significant
intelligence activities
it would appear reasonable to consider
that the cia's support for the sale of
arms to iran was a significant
intelligence activity
in short the written pledge of the
director in the spring of 1984
was not sufficient to ensure that the
congress was e
in short the written pledge of the
director in the spring of 1984
was not sufficient to ensure that the
congress was informed in january of 1986
i would suggest then mr chairman that
the establishment of
goodwill informed in january of 1986.
i would suggest then mr chairman that
the establishment of goodwill
and cooperation
between the executive branch and the two
congressional committees on intelligence
may be more important than written
and cooperation
between the executive branch and the two
congressional committees on intelligence
may be more important than written
agreements or provisions of law
the essential question is how to restore
mutual trust and confidence
we're very fortunate agreements or
provisions of law
the essential question is how to restore
mutual trust and confidence
we're very fortunate on the fourth of
march
the president in his address to the
nation on tv
stated unequivocally that his
administration had come to a new view on
the 4th of march
the president in his address to the
nation on tv
stated unequivocally that his
administration had come to a new view
that there must be congressional
oversight i quote
i'm also determined to make the
congressional oversight process work two
that there must be congressional
oversight
i quote
i'm also determined to make the
congressional oversight process work
proper procedures for consultation with
the congress will be followed not only
in the letter but the spirit
unquote
let me proper procedures for
consultation with the congress will be
followed
not only in the letter but the spirit
unquote
let me suggest that there might then be
some advantage
in allowing the executive to prove
itself in this regard without the
congress first
tightening the legal screws suggests
that there might then be some advantage
in allowing the executive to prove
itself in this regard without the
congress first tightening the legal
screws
i'm suggesting that this particular
moment
discretion on the part of congress may
be the better part of valor
when the intelligence community is
i'm suggesting that this particular
moment discretion on the part of
congress may be the better part of valor
when the intelligence community is
adjusting to the new presidential
directive it may be best not to sound
any more alarms than are necessary
especially not with a provision of law
adjusting to the new presidential
directive
it may be best not to sound any more
alarms than are necessary especially not
with a provision of law that may well
not be effective anyway
if there is not good will in addition
mr chairman i cannot speak for the
administration of course
that may well not be effective anyway if
there is not goodwill in addition
mr chairman i cannot speak for the
administration of course but you do
raise the specter
that the administration may find it
necessary to veto this bill if it comes
before it
i know this but you do raise the specter
that the administration may find it
necessary to veto this bill if it comes
before it
i know that when a similar provision was
discussed in 1980 in connection with the
intelligence oversight act of that year
i recommended to president carter that
he veto when a similar provision was
discussed in 1980 in connection with the
intelligence oversight act of that year
i recommend it to president carter that
he veto such a bill if it did pass the
congress and i believe the president was
inclined to do so at that time i would
hate to see at this particular juncture
such a bill if it did pass the congress
and i believe the president was inclined
to do so at that time i would hate to
see at this particular juncture that
kind of adversarial relationship
developed between the committees and the
administration as i mentioned
that kind of adversarial relationship
developed between the committees and the
administration
now as i mentioned
at the beginning
i would suggest there is one case
in which notification to the congress in
48 hours
poses a genuine concern the beginning
i would suggest there is one case
in which notification to the congress in
48 hours poses a genuine concern to the
intelligence professionals
that is when a chief of intelligence
finds
that it's desirable to ask an american
implant to the intelligence
professionals
that is when a chief of intelligence
finds
that it's desirable to ask an american
employee
or a foreign agent
to put his or her life on the line
in some covert activity
i did this
or a foreign agent
to put his or her life on the line
in some covert activity
i did this on three occasions
i would have found it very difficult to
look such an individual in the eye and
tell him or her that i was going to dis
on three occasions
i would have found it very difficult to
look such an individual in the eye and
tell him or her
but i was going to discuss this
life-threatening mission
with even half a dozen people in the cia
who did not absolutely have to know
discuss this life-threatening mission
with even half a dozen people in the cia
who did not absolutely have to know
that is who were not
necessarily and intimately involved in
supporting this activity
let me describe very briefly the three
that is who were not necessarily and
intimately involved in supporting this
activity
let me describe very briefly the three
instas instances to which i referred
all our efforts
in connection with the
attempt to release our hostages from
texas instances to which i referred
all our efforts in connection with the
attempt to release our hostages from
tehran in 1979 to eighty
i will only sketch them briefly
there are more details in the classified
appendix to my iran in nineteen seventy
nine to nineteen eighty
i will only sketch them briefly
there are more details in the classified
appendix to my
comments
first
as you will recall and as has been
mentioned earlier this morning
six americans escape comments
first as you will recall and as has been
mentioned earlier this morning
six americans escaped from the embassy
compound and eventually took refuge in
the residence of the canadian ambassador
we in the cia assumed response to baped
from the embassy compound and eventually
took refuge in the residence of the
canadian ambassador
we in the cia assumed responsibility for
obtaining the release of those six
americans
we did that
in part by sending in
a facility for obtaining the release of
those six americans
we did that
in part by sending in
a cia covert action professional
into tehran to engineer the departure of
these six
now for this person voluntarily to stay
ia covert action professional
into tehran to engineer the departure of
these six
now for this person voluntarily to step
into that hostile environment at that
time was an act of bravery and
self-sacrifice
only a bare handful of people in the cia
were privy to what went into that
hostile environment at that time was an
act of bravery and self-sacrifice only a
bare handful of people in the cia were
privy to what was going on
and in my conscience i could not inform
anyone else who was not essential to the
operation
we did proceed with going on
and in my conscience i could not inform
anyone else who was not essential to the
operation
we did proceed without informing the
congress as you know it was a highly
successful undertaking
the second instance concerned what has
come to be known as the without
informing the congress as you know it
was a highly successful undertaking
a second instance concerned what has
come to be known as the desert one
operation
the military needed to refuel
helicopters
as they flew from an aircraft carrier in
the arabian desert one operation
the military needed to refuel
helicopters
as they flew from an aircraft carrier in
the arabian sea
to tehran
they were having great difficulty in
finding any way to do this
without risk of revealing that on sea
to tehran
they were having great difficulty in
finding any way to do this
without risk of revealing that a rescue
effort was in progress
i asked the cia's covert action experts
to turn their minds loose on this
problem
they came a rescue effort was in
progress
i asked the cia's covert action experts
to turn their minds loose on this
problem
they came back to me in about a week
with the thought that the desert floor
in eastern iran
might be sufficiently firm to take the
fixed-wing aircraft back to me in about
a week with the thought that the desert
floor in eastern iran
might be sufficiently firm to take the
fixed wing aircraft
carrying the fuel for the helicopters
what's more
they actually flew a light plane into
the desert
carrying the fuel for the helicopters
what's more
they actually flew a light plane into
the desert by the light of a full moon
they took core samples and proved that
the desert floor was sufficiently firm
here again i was by the light of a full
moon they took core samples and proved
that the desert floor was sufficiently
firm
here again i was asking people to insert
themselves into a hostile country at
high risk
only a handful of cia people knew of
this venture
and was asking people to insert
themselves into a hostile country at
high risk
only a handful of cia people knew of
this venture
and we did not inform the congress
the third example
concerned providing support for the
rescue force
once it reached the environs we did not
inform the congress
the third example concerned providing
support for the rescue force
once it reached the environs of tehran
by helicopter
cia personnel went repeatedly into
hostile tehran
to survey what the rescue force would
follow tehran by helicopter
cia personnel went repeatedly into
hostile tehran
to survey what the rescue force would
find on its arrival
and to acquire trucks to transport the
men from where the helicopters would
drop them to the walls of the embassy
e mined on its arrival
and to acquire trucks to transport the
men from where the helicopters would
drop them to the walls of the embassy
each such trip into tehran was a highly
risky venture
and any hint that we were doing such a
thing
right through merhabad airport which
such trip into tehran was a highly risky
adventure
and any hint that we were doing such a
thing
right through merhabad airport would
certainly
have roused suspicions and raised the
possibility that our people would have
been caught in an iranian news
certainly
have roused suspicions and raised the
possibility that our people would have
been caught in an iranian noose
again very few individuals in the cia
knew of this activity and we did not
notify the congress
i bel
again very few individuals in the c i a
knew of this activity and we did not
notify the congress
i believe instances like these three
will be infrequent
i also believe the odds are high
that these would be the kinds of
operations believe instances like these
three will be infrequent
i also believe the odds are high
that these would be the kinds of
operations with which the congress would
agree
were they informed
there is though no guarantee of that
here though we come back to the question
of mutual to which the congress would
agree
were they informed
there is though no guarantee of that
here though we come back to the question
of mutual trust and confidence
i would hope that a president who
endorsed congressional oversight as
president reagan has just done
with trust and confidence
i would hope that a president who
endorsed congressional oversight as
president reagan has just done
would not undertake even a
life-threatening covert action
that was also a major change in foreign
policy without informing the kind not
undertake even a life-threatening covert
action
that was also a major change in foreign
policy without informing the congress
one other recent development will
minimize minimize the risk
that there will not be such notification
risks
one other recent development will
minimize minimize the risk that there
will not be such notification in cases
like that that's another new policy
which president reagan also enunciated
in his speech
on march march 4th
he's in cases like that
that's another new policy which
president reagan also enunciated in his
speech
on march march 4th
he said quote
i've also directed that any covert
activity be in support of clear policy
objectives
and incomplete quote
i've also directed that any covert
activity be in support of clear policy
objectives
and in compliance with american values
i expect a covert policy
that if americans saw it on the front
page of the newspaper clients with
american values
i expect a covert policy
that if americans saw it on the front
page of the newspaper they'd say
that makes sense unquote
that pledge not only makes sense i
believe it gives greater assurance
they'd say
that makes sense unquote
that pledge not only makes sense i
believe it gives greater assurance
that almost all covert actions conceived
by the executive will be acceptable to
the congress
finally mr chairman let me offer a
wonderance
that almost all covert actions conceived
by the executive will be acceptable to
the congress
finally mr chairman let me offer one
final suggestion
oversight of intelligence has broken
down but the fault is not entirely
with the executive
final suggestion
oversight of intelligence has broken
down
but the fault is not entirely
with the executive
the congress the media the public
we're all aware in august of 1985 that
lieutenant colonel oliver north
was engaged the congress the media the
public
we're all aware in august of 1985 that
lieutenant colonel oliver north
was engaged in activities in support of
the contras
whether or not these were legal or
illegal activities was unclear but there
was little question in any of the
activities in support of the contras
whether or not these were legal or
illegal activities was unclear
but there was little question in any of
our minds the colonel north was
deliberately attempting to circumvent
the spirit of the law governing support
to the contras
thus far minds the colonel north was
deliberately attempting to circumvent
the spirit of the law governing support
to the contras
thus the oversight process did not work
at a time the president needed the
advice of the congress
why he did not get that advice the
oversight process did not work at a time
the president
needed the advice of the congress
why he did not get that advice
is something that you know far more
about than i
i would only suggest that it is not
adequate to say that mr mcfarlane
is something that you know far more
about than i i would only suggest that
it is not adequate to say that mr
mcfarlane or others misled the congress
if that's a sufficient excuse the very
oversight process that we're
working on so hard is not worth the or
others misled the congress
if that's a sufficient excuse the very
oversight process that we're
working on so hard is not worth the
attention we're giving it
there is then some danger in my view
that the public and the congress might
look on this bill
as all attention we're giving it
there is then some danger in my view
that the public and the congress might
look on
this bill
as all of the action necessary by the
congress
to correct the recently disclosed
shortcomings in the oversight process
i would hope that all of the action
necessary by the congress
to correct the recently disclosed
shortcomings in the oversight process
i would hope that congress would
concentrate instead on measures to
improve its own conduct of oversight to
make it more rigorous
and
on steps to improve congress would
concentrate instead on measures to
improve its own conduct of oversight to
make it more rigorous
and
on steps to improve the relations
between the intelligence community and
the congress
we need mr chairman to return to
conditions where we can conduct
oversight the relations between the
intelligence community and the congress
we need mr chairman to return to
conditions where we can conduct
oversight in a cooperative and
constructive manner thank you sir thank
you very much admiral mr colby
mr chairman thank you for the invitation
in a cooperative and constructive manner
thank you sir thank you very much
admiral mr colby
mr chairman thank you for the invitation
i've read over this proposed bill mr
chairman and i think it is perfectly
understandable why the bill has come to
be
i've read over this proposed bill mr
chairman and i think it is perfectly
understandable why the bill has come to
be
the long delay in a timely of a timely
fashion obviously
was a violation of the concept of the
law the long delay in a timely of a
timely fashion obviously
was a violation of the concept of the
law
i think that in that situation one
should first look to the proper
execution of the law rather than
necessarily changing it every time i
think that in that situation one should
first look to the proper execution of
the law rather than necessarily changing
it every time we have a murder we don't
necessarily change the laws against
murder we we try to execute them better
and more effectively
when we have a
murder we don't necessarily change the
laws against murder we we try to execute
them
better and more effectively
the uh
we
you have a situation where the
administration was dealing with a ragtag
bunch of our middle east arms merchants
the uh we you have a situation where the
administration was dealing with a ragtag
bunch of our middle east arms merchants
and was not willing to share the same
information with the responsible
leadership of the congress i mean
obviously there's a contradiction there
a total contradiction and was not
willing to share the same information
with the responsible leadership of the
congress i mean obviously there's a
contradiction there a total
contradiction
even an estimate as to whether
that operation would have remained
secret is uh really highly highly
obvious that it couldn't possibly even
an estimate as to whether
that operation would have remained
secret is uh really highly highly
obvious that it couldn't possibly remain
secret uh considering the people that
the administration was dealing with
so
the fact is that the the law as a as it
remains secret uh considering the people
that the administration was dealing with
so
the fact is that the the law as a as it
existed was not really followed that's
uh oh we all know that
the problem of leaks is a very serious
one and it's a very serious one existed
was not really followed that's uh oh we
all know that
the problem of leaks is a very serious
one and the it's a very serious one to
share the leak the information with the
congress we all know from our personal
lives that if we have a secret we have a
secret but if we share it with someone
to share the leak the information with
the congress we all know from our
personal lives that if we have a secret
we have a secret but if we share it with
someone we have half a secret and if you
apply the same proportionality to the
kinds of secrets we have now i think
many of our very we have half a secret
and if you apply the same
proportionality to the kinds of secrets
we have now i think many of our very
serious national secrets are in the
category of a
0.0001 of a secret rather than
any kind of a real secret and it's
probably serious national secrets are in
the category of a
0.0001 of a secret rather than
any kind of a real secret and it's a
problem we're wrestling with i have a
great respect for the congress
i and its role of oversight i think it's
an essential part of our constitutional
system we're wrestling with i have the
great respect for the congress
i and its role of oversight i think it's
an essential part of our constitutional
system
uh it is not a a happenstance that this
is a select committee
it was set up as a select committee so
that the speak
it is not a a happenstance that this is
a select committee
it was set up as a select committee so
that the speaker and the
minority leader could be selective about
who appears on this
committee and they can keep the people
at the tunica and the
minority leader could be selective about
who appears on this
committee and they can keep the people
that they do not have faith in off the
committee they will have a difference of
opinion certainly but they will have a
faith that those people will be
responsible in their activity and have
faith in off the committee they will
have a difference of opinion certainly
but they will have a faith that those
people will be responsible in their
activities
the fact should the congress know
everything uh the fact is the answer to
that is obviously no
the fact
should the congress know everything uh
the fact is the answer to that is
obviously no
there are things that the congress
doesn't need to know
when we got into our first set of
investigations uh
there are things that the congress
doesn't need to know
when we got into our first set of
investigations of the agency
i called upon the chairman of the
various committees that were
investigating me and i said look i'm not
going to contest your constitution of
the agency i called upon the chairman of
the various committees that were
investigating me and i said look i'm not
going to contest your constitutional
right to know everything because that's
a dead issue i'll never win that we've
decided that we're having a
constitutional separation of power it's
no right to know everything because
that's a dead issue i'll never win that
we've decided that we're having a
constitutional separation of powers
but i want to convince you of the same
rule that we apply to ourselves in the
intelligence community it's called need
to know
do i
but i want to convince you of the same
rule that we apply to ourselves in the
intelligence community it's called need
to know
do i need to know some item of
information
because if i don't i shouldn't know it i
said i as director do not need to know i
need to know some item of information
because if i don't i shouldn't know it i
said i as director do not need to know
the names of individuals serving us
secretly in for instance eastern europe
i re i arrange my affairs so i don't
know the names of individuals serving us
secretly in for instance eastern europe
i re i arrange my affairs so i don't
know their names i know that there are
people there i know roughly how good the
information is all the rest of it but i
don't need to know their names and today
are names i know that there are people
there i know roughly how good the
information is all the rest of it but i
don't need to know their names and today
i don't know their names and i'm glad i
don't i had one effort by somebody to be
nice to one of these fellows and send
them a letter with my i don't know their
names and i'm glad i don't i had one
effort by somebody to be nice to one of
these fellows and send him a letter with
my signature at the bottom
congratulating him on what a good job he
had done
which i was quite willing to send my
name that was no problem but it had his
name my signature at the bottom
congratulating him on what a good job he
had done
which i was quite willing to send my
name that was no problem but it had his
name and i almost blew the roof off of
the place the idea of putting his name
on and my name on the same piece of
paper which was a death and i almost
blew the roof off of the place the idea
of putting his name on and my name on
the same piece of paper which was a
death warrant for that individual
there'd no question about it and i the
two chairman i'm delighted to say did
agree with me that they we would conduct
that massive investment for that
individual there's no question about it
and i the two chairmen i'm delighted to
say did agree with me that they we would
conduct that massive investigations into
american intelligence without the names
and uh i think that is the kind of
arrangement that can be made
investigations into american
intelligence without the names and uh i
think that is the kind of arrangement
that can be made
leave the constitutional issue aside
make the arrangement based on sense
the the
the law says that the congress will be
informed constitutional issue aside make
the arrangement based on sense
the the
the law says that the congress will be
informed in a timely fashion
and if the action is already taken
and
shall provide a statement of the reasons
armed in a timely fashion
and if the action is already taken
and
shall provide a statement of the reasons
for not giving prior notice
i think uh admiral turner has just given
us three reasons for not giving prior
notice and i don't think for not giving
prior notice
i think
admiral turner has just given us three
reasons for not giving prior notice and
i don't think anybody in the congress
would take issue with the fact that that
information was not passed to the
congress before or during that sensitive
operation anybody in the congress would
take issue with the fact that that
information was not passed to the
congress before or during that sensitive
operation though the fact is the
machinery's there
now whether the congress wants to go
ahead and counter a somewhat uh
well the fact is the machinery is there
now whether the congress wants to go
ahead and counter a somewhat uh
imaginative bit of legalese that a
finding could be oral and not in writing
it's a kind of micromanagement of the
president's office
imaginative bit of legalese that a
finding could be oral and not in writing
it's a kind of micromanagement of the
president's office and i think we really
have to let the president pretty well be
responsible for how he runs his office i
find that a rather marginal thing but
and i think we really have to let the
president pretty well be responsible for
how he runs his office i find that a
rather marginal thing but
i think that that
even this bill i might add has some
loopholes in it for instance it says at
the very top
to the extent i think that that
even this bill i might add has some
loopholes in it
for instance it says at the very top
to the extent consistent with due regard
for the protection of an of unauthorized
disclosure of classified information
uh
do rent consistent with due regard for
the protection of of unauthorized
disclosure of classified information
due regard for that in admiral turner's
case i think would say well i had due
regard for the importance of
protecting these sources these regard
for that in admiral turner's case i
think would say well i had due regard
for the importance of
protecting these sources these
individuals and therefore i didn't
follow the rest of the provision
it points out that below it says that
nothing in the actual kicks individuals
and therefore i didn't follow the rest
of the provision
it points out that below it says that
nothing in the action could be construed
as authority to withhold information
from the intelligence committees on
on grounds that providing it
to the committees would
constitute be construed as authority to
withhold information from the
intelligence committees on
on grounds that providing it to the
committees would
constitute the unauthorized disclosure
we're not talking about
whether giving it to the committee would
be an unauthorized disclosure we're
counting
counting upon the root the unauthorized
disclosure we're not talking about
whether giving it to the committee would
be an unauthorized disclosure we're
counting upon the risk to the due regard
for the protection of our intelligence
sources
so there is a loophole here
the congress can pass this laws to the
due regard for the protection of our
intelligence sources
so there is a loophole here
the congress can pass this law and if
some president doesn't want to follow
the sensible rules of getting along with
congress we're going to have another
meeting just like the and if some
president doesn't want to follow the
sensible rules of getting along with
congress we're going to have another
meeting just like this two three five
years from now at which somebody will
say well he's not allowed to have due
regard for that he's he's got to tell
everything
this two three five years from now at
which somebody will say well he's not
allowed to have due regard for that he's
he's got to tell everything
and then that won't pass because it
really doesn't make too much sense
so my conclusion mr chairman is uh
fairly senseless uh and then that won't
pass because it really doesn't make too
much sense
so my conclusion mr chairman is a fairly
sense uh simple
i think it does depend upon the
relationship between the committee and
the administration
that in this case there was a failure of
the simple
i think it does depend upon the
relationship between the committee and
the administration
that in this case there was a failure of
that relationship
and that this should be improved to
borrow a phrase from my neighbor the
admiral here i think the near sabbat
relationship
and that this should be improved to
borrow a phrase from my neighbor the
admiral here
i think the mere submission of this bill
and the holding of this hearings is a
shot across the bow or perhaps across
the stern
of the administration on this case
mission of this bill and the holding of
this hearings
is a shot across the bow or perhaps
across the stern
of the administration on this case
and that this will certainly be taken
due note i'm a great believer in the
case law system and which we don't try
to define every uh and that this will
certainly be taken due note i'm a great
believer in the case
law system in which we don't try to
define every last detail of
relationships but let developments
determine how the law is to be
interpreted and applied over the years
every last detail of relationships but
let developments
determine how the law is to be
interpreted and applied over the years
that's how our judicial system works and
i think it applies to this if i may as
one point mr chairman just take a moment
i think that's how our judicial system
works and i think it applies to this if
i may as one point mr chairman just take
a moment i think the speaker did miss
misspeak himself a bit uh
on a couple of details and i deeply
appreciate uh mr hyde's correcting the
speaker did miss misspeak himself a bit
on a couple of details and i deeply
appreciate uh mr hydes correcting the
record on the on the alien day situation
uh there was a cia operation there but
long before the coup
that was not a record on the
on the alien day situation
uh there was a cia operation there but
long before the coup
that was not a secret cia operation it
was directed by the president of the
united states very very precisely to the
then director of intelligence secret cia
operation it was directed by the
president of the united states very very
precisely to the then director of
intelligence and it was a legal order at
that time it would not meet the hughes
ryan requirements at this time but that
event came long before and it was a
legal order at that time it would not
meet the hughes ryan requirements at
this time but that event came long
before it
secondly the speaker referred to they
plan to destabilize chile i must take a
point of personal privilege on that
because
secondly the speaker referred to they
plan to destabilize chile i must take a
point of personal privilege on that
because that word was put in my mouth by
a former member of the congress uh and
it was proved to to the satisfaction of
the committee at that that word was put
in my mouth by a former member of the
congress
uh and it was proved to to the
satisfaction of the committee at that
time that i had never used that word i
would not use that word because that was
not our policy
and so that word has been improperly
assigned to the set time that i had
never used that word i would not use
that word because that was not our
policy and so that word has been
improperly assigned to the cia's
activities as mr hyde points out
and thirdly the our ben's case that the
speaker mentioned the cia did not have a
pia's activities as mr hyde points out
and thirdly the our ben's case that the
speaker mentioned the cia did not have a
plan to assassinate mr arbenz it had a
plan to overthrow it i think there is a
difference
and i would just like to clarify the
plan to assassinate mr arbenz it had a
plan to overthrow it i think there is a
difference
and i would just like to clarify that
for the record with great respect to the
speaker i'm afraid he was somewhat
misinformed on that
thank you very much mr colby dr klein
and for the record with great respect to
the speaker i'm afraid he was somewhat
misinformed on that
thank you very much mr colby dr klein
thank you very much mr chairman i
can be fairly brief because i want
thank you very much mr chairman i
can be fairly brief because i want to
begin by
associating myself with the views of my
two former colleagues
at the table with me
i that gives me to begin by
associating myself with the views of my
two former colleagues
at the table with me
i that gives me special pleasure because
uh i have been
worrying about intelligence operations
and congressional oversight for a
special pleasure because
i have been
worrying about intelligence operations
and congressional oversight for
more than 40 years and i was a chief of
the current intelligence staff for bill
donovan and oss when we dropped bill
colby into france and more than 40 years
and i was a chief of the current
intelligence staff for bill donovan and
oss when we dropped bill colby into
france and uh he's been doing well ever
since
and of course i was at oxford almost 10
years before stan turner so i i have
links with
he's been doing well ever since
and of course i was at oxford almost 10
years before
stan turner so i have links with these
gentlemen for a long time
and i agree with everything they said
today
my uh
familiarity with the congressional
gentleman for a long time and i agree
with everything they said today
my
familiarity with the congressional
oversight problem
is particularly
related to the
earlier period of congressional
oversight before these oversight
problems
is particularly
related to the
earlier period of congressional
oversight before these committees were
established when there were a variety of
committees
trying to observe what cia was doing
i often briefed the middies were
established when there were a variety of
committees
trying to observe what cia was doing
i often briefed them
the then committees in the 1960s when
senator richard russell and
representative carl vinson were the
principal congressional representative
then committees in the 1960s when
senator richard russell and
representative carl vinson were the
principal congressional representatives
and i can assure you they ran their
committees with a very firm hand
and the briefings were very thorough and
as far as i know these and i can assure
you they ran their committees with a
very firm hand
and the briefings were very thorough and
as far as i know
they learned everything
that they needed in the way of
understanding of
covert operations and sensitive
operations they learned everything that
they needed in the way of
understanding of
covert operations and sensitive
operations of all kind and i'm happy to
say in those days i'm not aware of any
leaks from congressional committees
it is a
happy day in some way all kind and i'm
happy to say in those days i'm not aware
of any leaks from congressional
committees it is a
happy day in in some ways uh compared to
our present controversial position it's
for that reason uh
recalling those days
that uh
compared to our present controversial
position it's for that reason uh
recalling those days
that uh
i want to say that i
feel obliged to make a single comment on
h.r 101.3
much along i want to say that i
feel obliged to make a single comment on
h.r 101.3
much along the lines that mr michael and
congressman hyde have already made so i
can be brief about that
in my view
these new amendment lines that mr
michael and congressman hyde have
already made so i can be brief about
that
in my view these new amendments
prescribe an unwarranted rigidity with
respect to timing of notification that's
essentially what the critics have been
saying forties prescribe an unwarranted
rigidity with respect to timing of
notification that's essentially what the
critics have been saying 48 hours or 14
months or whatever is a is a rigidity
however you define it they also are
counterproductive in the micro many
eight hours or 14 months or whatever
is a is a rigidity however you define it
they also are counterproductive in the
micro managerial
congressional intrusion into the
executive authority of the president to
conduct sensitive
national security
congressional intrusion
into the executive authority of the
president to conduct sensitive
national security operations i'm sure
that is not the intention but my
belief
uh based on running
clandestine 30 operations i'm sure that
is not the intention
but my
belief
uh based on running
clandestine and covert operations
is that there would be a chilling effect
from such close supervision by the
congress
and state covert operations
is that there would be a chilling effect
from such close supervision by the
congress
and stan turner has given you an example
of how that might be
and how the present law
allows those exceptions to be made
i think turner has given you an example
of how that might be
and how the present law
allows those exceptions to be made
i think the key is that mr stokes and mr
boland are right in saying that
and i quote mr stokes a congressional
committee's oversight efforts are
largely key is that mr stokes and mr
boland are right
in saying that
and i quote mr stokes a congressional
committee's oversight efforts are
largely dependent on the willingness of
the executive branch to provide
information
and bolin said there exists a serious
and fundamental disagreement but truly
dependent on the willingness of the
executive branch to provide information
and bolan said there exists a serious
and fundamental disagreement between the
executive branch and the congress over
the requirements of the existing law
he's referring of course to this
notification and a time between the
executive branch and the congress over
the requirements of the existing law
uh he's referring of course to this
notification in a timely fashion i
submit that
the the answer to that as has been
suggested by many
people
is not a dictate from the kung fashion i
submit that
the the answer to that as has been
suggested by many people
is not a dictate from the congress it is
an attempt to
work out a
reasonable cooperative relationship it
is an attempt to
work out a
reasonable cooperative
relationship between the executive
branch and these committees on the
question of what the
best
meaning of ship between the executive
branch and these committees on the
question of what the
best
meaning of prior notice and timely
fashion
is from the points of view of both of
the interested parties
and
and understand prior notice and timely
fashion
is from the points of view of both of
the interested parties and an
understanding that there may be an area
of ambiguity and flexibility in the
interpretation of that reasonable law
i believe this legislation being that
there may be an area of ambiguity and
flexibility in the interpretation of
that reasonable law
i believe this legislation departs from
that principle it smacks a little bit of
an attempt at a congressional political
coup to nail down its point of view
which clearly will be a departure from
that principle it smacks a little bit of
an attempt at a congressional political
coup to nail down its point of view
which clearly will be opposed by the
executive branch and i think correctly
so
it is certainly true and this is a
footnote in the previous discussion
posed by the executive branch and i
think correctly so
it is certainly true and this is a
footnote in the previous discussion i
can easily imagine operations where the
president makes a finding and
initiates a chain of events i can easily
imagine operations where the president
makes a finding
and
initiates a chain of events which may
well
not have
any
precise
impact
which may well
not have
any
precise
impact for
many hours many days or even many months
it was not totally it is not totally
impossible that there should be a very
for
many hours many days or even many months
it was not totally it is not totally
impossible that there should be a very
long lapse before
the necessity of timely notification
that congress exists that's a complex
and and often controversial long lapse
before uh the necessity of timely
notification the congress exists that's
a complex and and often controversial
subject but i believe you should
approach it with a view to the problems
of the executive branch and particularly
the intelligence officers in subject but
i believe you should approach it
with a view to the problems of the
executive branch and particularly the
intelligence officers in carrying out
what you want to be carried out if there
is such an operation to be taking place
an efficient secret operation
regrettably
carrying out what you want to be carried
out if there is such an operation to be
taking place an efficient secret
operation
uh regrettably as has been pointed out
the likelihood that uh
controversial covert action proposals on
sensitive operations will leak to the
press and the public in one way or
another pointed out the likelihood that
controversial covert action proposals on
sensitive operations will leak to the
press and the public in one way or
another if prior notice is rigidly
required
means the executive branch will be
hesitant will be forthcoming and may
forego
other if prior notice is rigidly
required
means the executive branch will be
hesitant will be forthcoming and may
forego
very important operations that would be
useful to the united states i think
that's something the congress ought to
be concerned about
the worst outcry important operations
that would be useful to the united
states i think that's something the
congress ought to be concerned about
the worst outcome of course would be a
prolonged dispute
and an adversarial climate between the
executive and legislative branches after
notification is given
of course would be a prolonged dispute
and an adversarial climate between the
executive and legislative branches after
notification is given the damage will be
as great from this as from the rather
exceptional cases in which delaying
notification more than 48 hours might
occur
the damage will be as great from this as
from the rather exceptional cases in
which delaying notification more than 48
hours might occur
the president certainly ought to have
the opportunity
to conduct high-risk high-win activities
in the foreign policy and national
security
the president certainly ought to have
the opportunity to conduct high-risk
high-wind activities in the foreign
policy and national security field
he should have the right to determine
when there is a good reason to delay
notification because of extreme
sensitivity to leakage in fairfield
he should have the right to determine
when there's a good reason to delay
notification because of extreme
sensitivity to leakage and failure
timely fashion that carefully wrought
phrase seems to me to be the best phrase
that you can use in the circumstances so
i would say rather than passing hr
1013 the house committee would be well
advised to promote a way of improving
security of information provided by the
oversight committees and their staffs
and to reassure the executive branch of
their ability to do this and to invited
by the oversight committees and their
staffs and to reassure the executive
branch of their ability to do this and
to invite a more cooperative and
informative attitude on that basis and i
would like just
in passing to endorse the
house joint a more cooperative and
informative attitude on that basis and i
would like just in passing to endorse
the house joint resolution 48 providing
for establishing a joint committee on
intelligence uh sponsored by congressman
hyde because that would be a move
resolution 48 providing for establishing
a joint committee on intelligence uh
sponsored by congressman hyde because
that would be a move
to soothe executive congressional
relations a step in the right direction
rather than one to exacerbate them
in summary then to soothe executive
congressional relations
step in the right direction rather than
one to exacerbate them
in summary then mr chairman i would just
like to say that i believe that
congressmen
have the duty to represent the views of
their constituents in giving broad
strategic and mr chairman i would just
like to say that i believe that
congressmen have the duty to represent
the views of their constituents in
giving broad strategic guidance to shape
u.s legislation and policy there's no
question about that
with respect to foreign policy and
national security the chief executive
also
guidance to shape u.s legislation and
policy there's no question about that
with respect to foreign policy and
national security the chief executive
also is plainly responsible for decision
making and execution of laws and
policies the congress should not try to
legislate the specific modalities is
plainly responsible for decision-making
and execution of laws and policies the
congress should not try to legislate the
specific modalities of the execution of
policies in the foreign policy and
national security field particularly
when the element of secrecy is involved
it does seem of the execution of
policies in the foreign policy and
national security field particularly
when the element of secrecy is involved
it does seem to me therefore
that is likely to reduce rather than
increase the effectiveness and the
cooperative relationship between the
congress and the jimmy therefore that is
likely to reduce rather than increase
the effectiveness and the cooperative
relationship between the congress and
the chief executive in dealing with
covert operations if 1013 is passed and
therefore i would
respectfully submit chief executive in
dealing with covert operations if 1013
is passed and therefore i would
respectfully submit that discussion of
the issue is better than passing a piece
of legislation on this item thank you
thank you very much dr klein uh you all
represent that discussion of the issue
is better than passing a piece of
legislation on this item thank you
thank you very much uh dr klein uh you
all represent a very significant amount
of experience and that's something we
should
uh take into account uh in our
consideration of these bills and so we
appreciate present a very significant
amount of experience and that's
something we should
uh take into account uh in our
consideration of these bills and so we
appreciate your your testimony
admiral turner i guess i would start uh
start with you
uh you mentioned in your statement that
uh your your testimony
admiral turner i guess i would start to
start with you
uh you mentioned in your statement that
the oversight process broke down in part
because
the congressional committees didn't
exercise sufficient aggression i suppose
in in pursuing the oversight process
broke down in part because the
congressional committees didn't exercise
uh sufficient aggression i suppose in
in pursuing the reports which were in
the press about
oliver north's activities in the white
house
that may be that may be true but i think
it's important to state for reports
which were in the press about
uh oliver north's activities in the
white house
that may be that may be true but i think
it's important to state for the record
that
when we read those reports
we invited mr mcfarland
to visit with us in the committee room
for the record
that
when we read those reports
we invited mr mcfarland
to visit with us in the committee room
we all had an opportunity to ask him
questions specifically about those
reports to determine whether or not
indeed the white house was engaged in
this type of
we all had an opportunity to ask him
questions specifically about those
reports to determine whether or not
indeed the white house was engaged in
this type of activity
mr mcfarlane assured us that he had
investigated this thoroughly and that
there was nothing to these reports
whatsoever
activity
mr mcfarlane assured us that he had
investigated this thoroughly and that
there was nothing to these reports
whatsoever
on a subsequent occasion
we visited uh mr north himself in the
situation room in the white house
and uh we inquired of him very special
on a subsequent occasion uh we visited
uh mr north himself in the situation
room in the white house
and we inquired of him very specifically
whether or not
he was involved in any of these
activities which were reported mr north
assured us that that was not the case
specifically whether or not
he was involved in any of these
activities which were reported mr north
assured us that that was not the case
um
now it is quite possible that we should
have
not taken them at their word
but frankly we're relying upon the kind
of trust and comedy now it is quite
possible that we should have
not taken them at their word
but frankly we're relying upon the kind
of trust and comedy which you gentlemen
are suggesting we rely upon in these
cases and we've learned
from bitter experience that we were lied
to
which you gentlemen are suggesting we
rely upon in these cases and we've
learned
from bitter experience that we were lied
to
and that indeed our congressional
oversight responsibility which is a
serious one
was compromised and in some respects we
feel
and that indeed our congressional
oversight responsibility which is a
serious one was compromised
and in some respects we feel
as you've suggested some responsibility
for that breakdown now the question of
course is how to deal with it hopefully
people will tell us the truth in the
future as you've suggested some
responsibility for that breakdown now
the question of course is how to deal
with it
hopefully people will tell us the truth
in the future
but the question here is whether or not
we should rely upon that hope or whether
or not there is some other framework
which will give further encouragement
to the one but the question here is
whether or not we should rely upon that
hope or whether or not there is some
other framework which will give further
encouragement
to the white house in future cases
so i want to make that statement because
while i think it's fair to say that we
might have been more aggressive and not
accepted white house in future cases
so i want to make that statement because
while i think it's fair to say that we
might have been more aggressive and not
accepted
the word of mr mcfarland and colonel
north
the fact is we did try and we did rely
upon those
representations to us
the word of mr mcfarland and colonel
north
the fact is we did try and we did rely
upon those
representations to us and we learned
in hindsight that
we were foolish to do so
now i think admiral you've presented us
with and we learned
in hindsight that
we were foolish to do so
now i think admiral you've presented us
with hard cases
the ones that you've outlined are
difficult cases because as you say
people's lives are in jeopardy
and you with hard cases
the ones that you've outlined are
difficult cases because as you say
people's lives are in jeopardy
and you as the responsible director have
to send people out to risk their lives
for
for the country in these cases
um who has the responsible director have
to send people out to risk their lives
for for the country in these cases
so you have but i think those cases that
you've described
uh pose one set of examples which are
important
so you have but but i think those cases
that you've described
uh pose one set of
examples which are important for us to
consider and the iran case
poses the other example
and they're both legitimate cases it
seems to me
for us to consider and the iran case
poses the other
example
and they're both legitimate cases it
seems to me
on the one hand in your situations there
were a handful of people in the
executive branch who necessarily had to
know
you said a handful and i'm not on the
one hand in your situations there were a
handful of people in the executive
branch who necessarily had to know you
said a handful and i'm not sure how many
that would be but presumably there were
at least a few others beside yourself
who knew about this
the question for us is whether or not
sure how many that would be but
presumably there were at least a few
others beside yourself who knew about
this
the question for us is whether or not
the key leaders of the congress would
not be as trustworthy to know that
information
as they're not
the key leaders of the congress would
not be as trustworthy to know that
information
as
the handful in the central intelligence
agency or the executive branch
naturally we're inclined to think that
the speaker of the house the minority
leader
a handful in the central intelligence
agency or the executive branch
naturally we're inclined to think that
the speaker of the house the minority
leader
the chairman of the intelligence
committee and the ranking member of the
intelligence committee and their
counterparts in the senate are
trustworthy people and can hold that
kind of very the chairman of the
intelligence committee and the ranking
member of the intelligence committee and
their counterparts in the senate
are trustworthy people and can hold that
kind of very sensitive information
carefully
on the other hand
in the iran case to the extent that it's
an example and we have to consider
information carefully
on the other hand
in the iran case to the extent that it's
an example and we have to consider it as
one here
the fact that the president did not
notify or consult with anyone in
congress in part at least contributed to
where it is one here
the fact that the president did not
notify or consult with anyone in
congress
in part at least contributed to
not just the fact that congress wasn't
notified
but contributed to what i think most of
us would consider a very substantial
amount of damage to americans not just
the fact that congress wasn't notified
but contributed to what i think most of
us would consider a very substantial
amount of damage to american interests
our counterterrorism policy is in shreds
as a result of this foolish policy of
selling arms to iran
as this as the minority leaders our
counterterrorism policy is in shreds as
a result of this foolish policy of
selling arms to iran
as this as the minority leader and the
speaker have both said they would have
objected strongly if the president had
shared this notion with them in advance
and presumably it might have helped the
void peter and the speaker have both
said they would have objected strongly
if the president had shared this notion
with them in advance
and presumably it might have helped
avoid
not just a failure to notify congress
but
would have avoided this very substantial
damage so these two
uh cases
not just a failure to notify congress
but
uh would have avoided this very
substantial damage so these two
uh cases yours on the one hand which are
compelling cases i admit
but the iran situation on the other
pose these conflicting interests wars on
the one hand which are compelling cases
i admit but the iran situation on the
other
pose these conflicting interests for us
and uh
the real
the real question for us i think is
whether or not
uh first in us
and
the real
the real question for us i think is
whether or not uh first in limited
situations where there is a sensitivity
such as you've described
the leadership this handful of eight
people
can be trusted in limited situations
where there is a sensitivity such as
you've described
the leadership this handful of eight
people
can be trusted with this sensitive
information and i guess my question is
do you have any thing in your experience
to indicate
that these
with this sensitive information
and i guess my question is do you have
any thing in your experience to indicate
that these
leadership
people cannot be trusted even with the
most sensitive information no sir i i
certainly do not
leadership
people cannot be trusted even with the
most sensitive information no sir i i
certainly do not
let me say though that i would not have
told eight people in the cia
who were not involved in it it's not a
question are they remember
let me say though that i would not have
told eight people in the cia
who were not
involved in it it's not a question are
they members of congress it's a question
of
looking a person in the eye
and saying i'm going to tell even one
person who isn't in congress it's a
question of
looking a person in the eye
and saying i'm going to tell even one
person who isn't involved in this in a
way that's necessary to support your
activity
i'd also point out that it can get much
more complicated as it was in the
involved in this in a way that's
necessary to support your
activity
i'd also point out that it can get much
more complicated as it was in the
three cases i cited
had we taught first of all i didn't have
the option of eight at that time because
the intelligence oversight of 1980 had
not been passed
three cases i cited
had we taught first of all i didn't have
the option of eight at that time because
the intelligence oversight of 1980 had
not been passed
so i would have taken my chances if i'd
gone to the members the chairman and
ranking minority members of the two
intelligence committees that whether
they would have
so i would have taken my chances if i'd
gone to the members the chairman and
ranking minority members of the two
intelligence committees that whether
they would have kept it to themselves i
mean limited the the amount of
disclosure
that is whether they would have agreed
that only they would
have responsibility for kept it to
themselves i mean limited the
the amount of disclosure
that is whether they would have agreed
that only they would have responsibility
for knowing that
but in that case we had another curious
connection because the president under
war powers act had not informed
the armed services committee knowing
that
but in that case we had another curious
connection because the president under
war powers act had not informed
the armed services committees or the
foreign relations committees that there
was
a rescue operation contemplated we were
a subsidiary supporting part of it
or the foreign relations committees that
there was
a rescue operation contemplated we were
a subsidiary supporting part of it
and had we come to the intelligence
committees or the eight leaders of
congress to inform them
that intelligence was participating in a
support and had we come to the
intelligence committees or the eight
leaders of congress to inform them
that intelligence was participating in a
supporting action
surely the other committees would have
to have been included too so the number
would have ballooned to at least 16
at that point
again boarding action
surely the other committees would have
to have been included too so the number
would have ballooned to at least 16
at that point
again
certainly the 16 top people in these
areas of the congress are are reliable
but
we're foolish they're certainly the 16
top people in these areas of the
congress are are reliable
but
we're foolish
if we say the congress can't be trusted
it always leaks
we're equally foolish if we say the
congress never leaks
when you're dealing in a city if we say
the congress can't be trusted it always
leaks
we're equally foolish if we say the
congress never leaks
when you're dealing in a situation like
this even though i think the congress
has a better record than the
executive branch as far as leaks is
concerned the congress does leak
executive tuition like this even though
i think the congress has a better record
than the
executive branch as far as leaks is
concerned the congress does leak the
executive branch leaks more
but it isn't a question of a better
record here when a man or a woman's life
is at stake
because even
ranch leaks more
but it isn't a question of a better
record here when a man or a woman's life
is at stake
because even
if you're ten times as reliable as the
executive branch if the leak did happen
to come from one of the people notified
in the in the congress if you're ten
times as reliable as the executive
branch if the leak did happen to come
from one of the people notified in the
in the congress somebody may have lost
his life unnecessarily
thank you very much mr livingston
all right thank you
[Music]
somebody may have lost his life
unnecessarily
thank you very much mr lewis
all right thank you
there's been some discussion about
the time limits
there's been some discussion about
the time limits and i think uh
mr hyde said split the difference
between
14 months and 48 hours i know you've
said it facetiously
uh
is this legislation i'd say split the
difference between
14 months and 48 hours i know you said
it facetiously
uh
is this legislation any more palatable
if you extend the the deadline for uh
for notice
and actually said and aren't any more
palatable
if you extend the the deadline for uh
for notice
and actually set an arbitrary time limit
uh be it uh
48 hours a month two months six months
10 months a year what have you
done arbitrary time limit
be it
48 hours a month two months six months
10 months a year what have you
does it become more palatable or do your
objections still lie
my objection still still lies
i don't think 14 months what become more
palatable or do your objections still
lie
my objection still still lies
i don't think 14 months was illegal or
unreasonable i think taking
that loophole was wrong in the first
place
but if it was illegal or
unreasonable i think taking
that loophole was wrong in the first
place
but if the president's reasons for not
notifying the congress up
in a really
instantaneous manner worked correct
the president's reasons for not
notifying the congress up
in a really
instantaneous manner worked correct
14 months is not to me untimely the
timely is not measured by a clock the
timely is measured by this risk
14 months is not to me untimely the
timely is not measured by a clock the
timely is measured by this risk
and i waited three months in the one
case i mean we were three months getting
this canadian six people out we were six
months
doing the other two operations and i
waited three months in the one case i
mean we were three months getting this
canadian six people out we were six
months
doing the other two operations that i i
mentioned to you so i don't think you we
should focus on hours and days i think
we should focus on
the completion that i i mentioned to you
so i don't think you we should focus on
hours and days i think we should focus
on
the completion
or the diminution of the risk it could
be that as an operation goes along the
risk drops off to human life but the
operation under the
or the diminution
of the risk it could be that as an
operation goes along the risk drops off
to human life but the operation under
the finding is still continuing and that
would be the point that the executive
should come when that risk of human life
is
diminished sufficiently is when its
timing is still continuing and that
would be the point that the executive
should come when that risk of human life
is
diminished sufficiently is when it's
timely to notify the congress in my
opinion sir
mr kobe basically concur i would not
limit it only to the human life problem
there emily to notify the congress in my
opinion sir
mr copeland basically concur i would not
limit it only to the human life problem
there are many other things
people
take risks with their lives for various
reasons and don't get very upset about
it but there are some
many other things
people
take risks with their lives for various
reasons and don't get very upset about
it but there are some other things that
are of more importance than the human
life of some of our people and
they understand that when they go in the
business they know that
uh
other things that are of more importance
than the human life of some of our
people and
they understand that when they go in the
business they know that
uh i do think that the one answer to the
question is that the timely fashion is
obviously
a general word it requires do think that
the one answer to the question is that
the timely fashion is obviously
a general word it requires a judgment
but the to respond to the chairman's
example of the discussions with uh
colonel north and uh mr
as a judgment
but the to respond to the chairman's
example of uh the discussions with uh
colonel north and uh mr
uh
then the others about that there is a
statute that makes it a criminal offense
not to fully inform the congress
uh and uh
than the others about that there is a
statute that makes it a criminal offense
not to fully inform the congress
and
this has been very rarely used but in
the case of a direct contradiction of
the of the truth i think that's
something this has been very rarely used
but in the case of a direct
contradiction of the of the truth i
think that's something that the
independent councils will be looking
into
and that that's that is the remedy in
other words the question is is there a
remedy anything that the independent
councils will be looking into
and that that's that is the remedy in
other words the question is is there a
remedy and the answer is yes there is a
remedy for a violation of the law and
there it is
mr clare
well
the answer is yes there is a remedy for
a violation of the law and there it is
mr clare
well i
simply
concur in the view that
defining timely fashion
in a number of hours or a day
i simply
concur in the view that
defining timely fashion
in a number of hours or days or months
is a solomon's uh exercise a a a paradox
that cannot be resolved by this
committee or by anybody's or months is a
solomon's uh exercise a a paradox that
cannot be resolved by this committee or
by anybody else it depends on these
complex factors that
my colleagues have mentioned and i i
think discussing it is wise i think
trying to else it depends on these
complex factors that
my colleagues have mentioned and i i
think discussing it is wise i think
trying to
cut the guardian knot with a slice of
the sword is not not a wise decision and
i can
definitely
cut cut the guardian knot with a slice
of the sword is not not a wise decision
and i can
definitely
visualize operations
where the
success factor
is prolonged you don't know it will
visualize operations
where the
success factor
is prolonged you don't know it'd be a
long time to get blocks in place before
you get the final result and that the
risk would be very great for many many
months so i i don't even long time to
get blocks in place before you get the
final result and that the risk would be
very great for many many months so i i
don't even
i don't even agree with the 14 months
maybe there would be cases in which uh
that time was not the objectionable
feature and i think
i don't even agree with the 14 months
maybe there would be cases in which uh
that time was not the objectionable
feature and i think
the objection to the handling of the
iran issue is not over the timeliness
it's over the fact that there was a
difference of view about the operation
it's
the objection to the handling of the
iran issue is not over the timeliness
it's over the fact that there was a
difference of view about the operation
itself and i think quite frankly i think
that in some cases you might get a
situation where if you have the timely
fashion requirement and the eight
individuals listed alph quite frankly i
think that in some cases you might get a
situation where if you have the timely
fashion requirement and the eight
individuals listed
that if the thing began to get at the
edge of the timely
i could envisage a president talking to
the speaker and the ranking minority
member only that if the thing began to
get at the edge of the timely
i could envisage a president talking to
the speaker and the ranking minority
member only and trying to get their
acceptance of not going any further with
it i mean i don't think you can write
that in the law but it's clearly what
and trying to get their acceptance of
not going any further with it i mean i
don't think you can write that in the
law but it's clearly what uh admiral
turner was
referring to that he didn't feel that he
could do at that early time school but
you mentioned uh you you
saw a situation admiral turner was
referring to that he didn't feel that he
could do at that early time skill but
you mentioned uh you you
saw situations uh that uh
might
mandate the withholding of information
from congress
that
might
mandate the withholding of information
from congress uh in in in other than
life threatening situations could you
elaborate on that could you give us a
couple of examples well you could have a
highly sensitive uh penetration industry
in in other than life-threatening
situations could you elaborate on that
could you give us a couple of examples
well you could have a highly sensitive
uh penetration into some terribly
important situation which took you
months and months to set up
and which could have a major effect on
the police some terribly important
situation which took you months and
months to set up
and which could have a major effect on
the political direction of an of another
country
and a an adversary country and you just
couldn't take any risk at all political
direction of another country
and a an adversary country and
you just couldn't take any risk at all
with that operation it would be a
high-stakes operation
and you just
you not only
if it didn't work you'd live with that
operation it would be a high stakes
operation
and you just
not only
if it didn't work you'd lose a great
opportunity
but if it were revealed you would suffer
a great deal and your nation could
suffer a great deal you might have a
cause of war on your hands who's a great
opportunity
but if it were revealed you would suffer
a great deal and your nation could
suffer a great deal you might have a
cause of war on your hands
for all you know you gentleman chair
that do you
yes yes i do
and can i add another refinement
for all you know you gentleman chair
love you
yes yes i do
and could i add another refinement which
i
since we're really discussing this issue
philosophically
attempt to understand it rather than
come to a solution
h.i
since we're really discussing this issue
philosophically
attempt to understand it rather than
come to a solution
a covert
intelligence operation may well begin
as a an intelligence
collection
effort a covert
intelligence operation may well begin
as a
an intelligence collection
effort a penetration
if you get a source in a foreign country
who will give you a lot of information
and then you find out he can do
something a penetration
if you get a source in a foreign country
who will give you a lot of information
and then you find out he can do
something politically that is terribly
important to your country he becomes a
covert action source at that point and
when you lay on an operation becomes
politically that is terribly important
to your country he becomes a covert
action source at that point and when you
lay on an operation becomes rather
ambiguous so i feel we're trying to to
deal with a very fluid situation here as
if it were were constitutional law
they're ambiguous so i feel we're trying
to to deal with a a very fluid situation
here as if it were were constitutional
law and it's not it's a matter of
executive judgment when the covert
action begins
so i i think we're just saying it's a
very and it's not it's a matter of
executive judgment when the covert
action begins
so i i think we're just saying it's a
very complicated thing and there may
well be good grounds to reserve judgment
on when to notify the congress if this
legislation were passed as is
complicated thing and there may well be
good grounds to reserve judgment on when
to notify the congress
if this legislation were passed as is
would
any of you or all of you anticipate any
instances in which you might refrain
from undertaking some dangerous but very
important intelligent activities
would
any of you or all of you anticipate any
instances in which you might refrain
from undertaking some dangerous but very
important intelligent activities
because of concerns about participants
safety or for the other reasons that
you've oh i i wanted to suggest that
there there might be a chilling effect
because of concerns about participants
safety or for the other reasons that
you've oh i i wanted to suggest that
there might be a chilling effect on
planners and and decision makers
thinking perhaps that they had a
perfectly legitimate intelligence
objective which might turn into on
planners and and decision makers
thinking perhaps that they had a
perfectly legitimate intelligence
objective which might turn into a very
great covert action opportunity but
saying oh my god if we go down and
explain this today uh it'll be
washed out or into a very great covert
action opportunity but saying oh my god
if we go down and explain this today
uh it'll be
washed out or it'll be blown uh we we
shouldn't do it yes i would think you
might well
miss opportunities with that kind of uh
uh it's not so much it'll be blown uh we
we shouldn't do it yes i would think you
might well uh miss opportunities with
that kind of uh uh it's not so much the
language you're putting across but the
attitude that uh the
the watchdogging of of
these
sensitive and the language you're
putting across but the attitude that uh
the watchdogging of
these
sensitive and difficult operations might
cause people to refrain we would once
again have to go around and hold a lot
of hands
of our agents
difficult operations might
cause people to refrain we would once
again have to go around and hold a lot
of hands
of our agents of
our liaisons
saying well now wait a minute the
congress is going to demand knowing
everything you do within 48 hours are
you kidding i'm gonna get our liaisons
saying well now wait a minute the
congress is going to demand knowing
everything you do within 48 hours are
you kidding
i'm going to get involved in that with
you not a chance we had quite a problem
with that when the first
thing of congressional review and we
sort of
were involved in that with you not a
chance we had quite a problem with that
when the first
thing of congressional review and we
sort of
wobbled our way through it but
it's still there with some countries
some countries still have a reservation
because
some of them don't have the same high
respect for the members wobbled our way
through it but
it's still there with some countries
some countries still have a reservation
because
some of them don't have the same high
respect for the membership of committees
that we do
the problem will be
we won't know
which covert actions are not membership
of committees that we do
the problem will be
we won't know
which covert actions are not proposed by
the professionals because they have this
concern inside and the people at the
top won't hear about them i'm afraid
posed by the professionals because they
have this concern inside and the people
at the top
won't hear about them i'm afraid
thank you chairman let me get the
outside uh
expressed my appreciation to all three
of our panelists uh three very distinct
mr thank you thank you mr chairman let
me get the outset uh
express my appreciation to all three of
our panelists a very very distinguished
gentleman who
appeared here this morning
ms kobe let me ask you
you made the statement there are things
that congress does not need an english
gentleman who
appeared here this morning scoby let me
ask you
you made the statement there are things
that congress does not need to know
you do not include in that
category do you
illegal or criminal activity by no
you do not include in that uh category
do you
illegal or criminal activity by members
of absolutely not the government no sir
so that provision i think is clear that
uh if anything illegal or improper comes
up
absolutely not the government no sir no
so that that provision i think is clear
that uh if anything illegal or improper
comes up the requirement is to report it
and there's no no ifs and some thoughts
about that one
in terms of uh
of iran and the requirement is to report
it and there's no no ifs and buts about
that one
in terms of uh
of iran and the iran situation
how would you classify that something
that congress
needed to know or should not have known
i think that
iran situation how would you classify
that something that congress
needed to know or should not have known
i think that uh
i would go back to the point that
that
what congress doesn't need to know is
the details of a policy
program a policy operation i would go
back to the point that
that
what congress doesn't need to know is
the details of a policy
program a policy operation it should
know about a general policy
and i think the general policy of
selling arms to the iranians is
something that it should know about a
general policy
and i think the general policy of
selling arms to the iranians is
something that the congress should know
about
they don't have to know who the
intermediary is that's really a detail
that's beyond them sources and methods
the congress should know about
they don't have to know who the
intermediary is that's really a detail
that's beyond them sources and methods
that's right yeah
but the general policy they should be
aware the general policy that you're
going to go right against your overtly
expressed policy
that's right yeah
but the general policy they should be
aware the general policy that you're
going to go right against your overtly
expressed policy uh i would certainly
say uh you better check that one out i
mean we have had coverts actions in the
past which have contradicted the
impression we've given certainly say uh
you better check that one out i mean we
have had coverts actions in the past
which have
contradicted the impression we've given
to different countries but those you can
explain to congress and if they make
sense the congress will buy it if it
doesn't make sense the congress will
object to it
given to different countries but those
you can explain to congress and if they
make sense the congress will buy it if
it doesn't make sense the congress will
object to it
well
you know basically i think that's what
we're trying to to keep intact and that
is
what all of you have addressed
well you know basically i think that's
what we're trying to to keep intact and
that is
uh what all of you have addressed and
that is a special relationship between
the executive branch and the congress
based upon some degree of mutual uh
trust and forthrightness and connect as
a special relationship between the
executive branch and the congress
uh based upon some degree of mutual uh
trust and forthrightness and candidness
um
and it's difficult for
for us to conceive of a situation where
uh when we talk about the
gang-handedness
um
and it's difficult for for us to
conceive of a situation where when we
talk about the gang of eight for
instance we're talking about the
speaker of the house
the majority minority leader of the
house chairman of the intelligence
committee and then of eight for instance
we're talking about the
speaker of the house the majority
minority leader of the house chairman of
the intelligence committee and then
similar
officials on the other side
it would seem to us that
these are highly responsible
similar
officials on the other side
uh it would seem to us that
these are highly responsible positions
people who are obviously concerned about
the national security of the united
states and not irresponsibly and
it will position people who are
obviously concerned about the national
security of the united states
not irresponsibly and
it would just seem that
if the president because of the high
risk of some type of adventure it would
just seem that
if the president because of the high
risk of some type of a venture and a
high risk of
human life felt that he uh just could
not tell both intelligence committees
that at least
uh the gang of eight so high risk of
human life
felt that he
just could not tell both intelligence
committees that at least
uh the gang of eight so to speak would
be given this information and i would
think we would all look at them as being
responsible individuals who would not
be leaking highly speak would be given
this information and i would think we
would all look at them as being
responsible individuals who would not
be leaking highly sensitive information
or data that would possibly cause the
loss of human life
a
list of information
or data that would possibly cause the
loss of human life
uh
let me ask you this mr uh admiral turner
uh
what in your opinion in those three
cases to cite and there let me ask you
this mr uh admiral turner uh
what in your opinion in those three
cases to cite and they are three very
classic uh cases they're very difficult
to argue with
uh as has been stated by uh
by chairman hugh three very classic uh
cases they're very difficult to argue
with
uh as has been stated by uh
by chairman hugh
what in your opinion would have been
reasonable knowledge assuming that we
had timely notice in the law at that
time
what in your opinion
what in your opinion would have been
reasonable knowledge assuming that we
had timely notice in the law at that
time
what in your opinion would have been
timely with reference to those matters
when my agents came out of
risk came out of iran one in would have
been timely with reference to those
matters
when my agents came out of
risk came out of iran when the
people went in to support the canadian
six were aboard the airplane and on
their way
home for instance sir
now the canadians the
people went in to support the canadian
six were aboard the airplane and on
their way
home for instance sir
now the canadian sixth matter you were
able to accomplish within about 48 hours
weren't you
no the the agent who went in stayed in
tehran about a week
sixth matter you were able to accomplish
within about 48 hours weren't you
no the the agent who went in stayed in
tehran about a week
but we were we were all three months
three and a half months before that
actually took place
preparing it working with the canadians
but we were we were all three months
three and a half months before that
actually took place
preparing it working with the canadians
preparing the documentation the cover
the
new personalities new jobs new
identities for these individuals is
preparing the documentation the cover
the
new personalities new jobs new
identities for these individuals and
getting that uh
training done so the six
new knew who they were and why they were
in iran
so they could answer a question
getting that
training done so the six
knew who they were and why they were in
iran
so they could answer questions when they
came out
you know about the one who
got quizzed on his passport mr stokes he
he
happens when they came out
you know about the one who
got got quizzed on his passport mr
stokes he
he uh
customs inspector said i notice your
middle initial is h
and you're on a west german passport
and i've never seen a west german past
customs inspector said i notice your
middle initial is h
and you're on a west german passport
and i've never seen a west german
passport in which the middle name wasn't
spelled out
and
this state department employee with
great resourcefulness looked up and said
yes in which the middle name wasn't
spelled out
and
this state department employee with
great resourcefulness looked up and said
yes
you'll note i was born in 1935 i'm
ashamed of my middle name
hitler
you'll note i was born in 1935 i'm
ashamed of my middle name
hitler
because it could very well
or the president could very well
substitute for it
because it could very well
or the president could very well
substitute for it
uh political risk
as i'm sure probably the decision was
made in terms of iran more than in terms
of any
any uh political risk as i'm sure
probably the decision was made in terms
of iran more than in terms of any
any uh
risk to human life that it was more on
the political risk
how do you see that it's a danger and
the admitted
risk to human life that it was more on
the political risk
how do you see that
it's a danger and
the administration the president
administration
when first justifying not notifying the
congress about the cia role in the iran
administration president administration
when first justifying not notifying the
congress about the cia role in the iran
affair
did claim
human life they claimed that the lives
of the hostages held in beirut might be
jeopardized if it came unfair
did claim
human life they claim that the lives of
the hostages held in beirut might be
jeopardized if it came out the united
states was collaborating with israel to
get the hostages out and
there is undeniably a
shred of argumentation there i think
about the united states was
collaborating with israel to get the
hostages out and
there is undeniably a
shred of argumentation there i think
it's not more than a shred sir so
yes
but i think we're all three trying to
say that there's no way to legislate
these boundaries it's not more than a
shred sir so
yes uh but i think we're all three
trying to say that there's no way to
legislate
these boundary lines uh
without
risking pushing yourself up against an
unreasonable
position you've got to have reasonable
men their
lines
without
risking pushing yourself up against
unreasonable position you've got to have
reasonable men there
that's a true story
sorry
that's a true story
sorry
that is a good one
my last question to to three of you
would be this
that is a good one
but
my last question to the three of you
would be this
uh i'm reluctant
in terms of the
the criteria standard
of risk to human life
uh i'm reluctant
in terms of the
the criteria standard
of risk to human life
to accept that as as sole criteria
what we're talking about is a subjective
evaluation made by the
uh to accept that as as sole criteria
what we're talking about is a subjective
evaluation made by the president
and
it's very difficult if we set that up as
the criteria
to be sure that that criteria is always
your president
and uh it's very difficult if we set
that up as the criteria
to be sure that that criteria is always
used in the sense that it is subjective
because it could very well or the
president could very well substitute for
it
uh political use in the sense that it is
subjective
because it could very well
uh or the president could very well
substitute for it
uh political risk
as i'm sure probably the decision was
made in terms of iran more than in terms
of any
any uh
risk
as i'm sure probably the decision was
made in terms of iran more than in terms
of any
any uh
risk to human life it was more on the
political risk
how do you see that
it's a danger and
the administration's risk to human life
that it was more on the political risk
how do you see that
it's a danger and
the administration present
administration
when first justifying not notifying the
congress about the cia role in the iran
affair president administration
when first justifying not notifying the
congress about the c.i.a role in the
iran
affair
did claim
human life they claimed that the lives
of the hostages held in beirut
might be jeopardized if it came out the
united
did claim
human life they claimed that the lives
of the hostages held in beirut might be
jeopardized if it came out the united
states was collaborating with israel to
get the hostages out and
there is undeniably a
shred of argumentation there i think
it's not more that states was
collaborating with israel to get the
hostages out and there is undeniably a
shred of argumentation there i think
it's not more than a shred sir so yes uh
but i think we're all three trying to
say that there's no way to legislate
these boundary lines
shred sir so
yes
but i think we're all three trying to
say that there's no way to legislate
these boundary lines
without
risking pushing yourself up against an
unreasonable
position you've got to have reasonable
men there
as well as
without
risking pushing yourself up against an
unreasonable
position you've got to have reasonable
men there
as well as here to interpret them
as i said i think the human life is not
the only judge should not be
but the congress here to interpret them
as i said
i think the human life is not the only
judge should not be
but the congress control on this is that
the requirement
that the president explain why he
delayed
now either that explanation will be
accepted when it's control on this is
that the requirement that the president
explain why he delayed
now either that explanation will be
accepted when it's given
or you will have a challenge to it
it'll be an after the fact challenge but
it's nonetheless a requirement that he
just upon him
or he will have a challenge to it uh
it'll be an after the fact challenge but
it's nonetheless a requirement that he
justify
to the congress the fact that he did not
pass over that information
and that's why i suggest that a
president will probably seek some middle
class to the congress the fact that he
did not pass over that information
and that's why i suggest that a
president will probably seek some middle
ground between forming and forming all
eight
and uh yet not telling anybody i think
that
the pressures on him round between
forming and forming all eight and uh yet
not telling anybody i think that
the pressures on him will be well eight
people is a lot of people uh and that
you learn in the executive branch when
you find out how many people are in on a
secret it becomes will be well eight
people is a lot of people
and that you learn in the executive
branch when you find out how many people
are in on a secret it becomes such a
small secret in the in group despite the
loyalty of all the people in the group
it becomes a general conversation among
such a small secret in the in group
despite
the loyalty of all the people in the
group
it becomes a general conversation among
them and it begins to slip out to
secretaries and assistance and all that
sort of thing just inevitably
and so the attempt would be made to them
and it begins to slip out to secretaries
and assistance and all that sort of
thing
just inevitably
and so the attempt would be made to
limit it
less than the eight
right
yeah i i would just add two comments
limited
less than the eight
right
yeah i i would just add two comments one
i think the
very valuable role of these
congressional committees is to try to
keep the executive branch advice one i
think the
very valuable role of these
congressional committees is to try to
keep the executive branch advised of
what seems
sensible from a point of view of
strategic coherence and continuity you
should be advising on broad eyes to what
seems
sensible from a point of view of
strategic coherence and continuity you
should be advising on broad issues
not exactly whether someone's life is at
risk or not because those are very
professional and subjective judgment
issues
not exactly whether someone's life is at
risk or not because those are very
professional and subjective judgments
and and i hope that
there will be a greater receptivity to
uh advice back and forth on these
matters and uh
that's an and i hope that uh
there will be a greater receptivity to
uh advice back and forth on these
matters and uh
and i believe it it can happen as as i
said in earlier days i think we had a
better understanding between the
congress and the
the executive and i believe it can
happen as as i said in earlier days i
think we had a better understanding
between the congress and the
the executive people in the intelligence
business and it worked pretty well uh
the second thing though relates to the
later comments uh
uh i the people in the intelligence
business and it worked pretty well
the second thing though relates to the
later comments uh
uh i
with all respect i want to
tell you that the congress
is a tremendous
with all respect i want to
tell you that the congress
is a tremendous target for the release
of unauthorized information there's
everybody in the city is trying to get
you
members who have seen tremendous target
for the release of unauthorized
information there's everybody in the
city is trying to get you
members who have secrets to disclose
them and
the
more your heads are full
of details about operations that should
not twitch to disclose them and
the
more your heads are full
of details about operations that should
not be disclosed the more in hazard you
and your staff members and people who
even overhear or guess at some of the
subjects discussed be disclosed the more
in hazard you and your staff members and
people who even overhear or guess at
some of the subjects discussed are
likely to be
tripped up or trapped not only by
foreign intelligence agents of which
there are hundreds wandering around
capitol hill are likely to be
tripped up or trapped not only by
foreign intelligence agents of which
there are hundreds wandering around
capitol hill all the time but by the
most
most expert espionage group in town the
u.s press uh they they they they all the
time but by uh the most uh
most expert espionage group in town the
u.s press uh they they
they do everything that intelligence
agencies do to try to elicit and and uh
if necessary uh
uh do everything that intelligence
agencies do to try to elicit and and
if necessary
somewhat in somewhat
unusual irregular fashion get someone to
disclose things off the record that they
should not disclose something somewhat
captioning not
that available the congressional
committees lead so you are an important
target and i think you ought not to look
at
suggestions that uh the congressional
committees leak as a kind of moral and
and personal issue and that's certainly
true of the eight men you were talking
about everyone assumes they're extremely
as a kind of moral and uh
and personal issue and that's certainly
true of the eight men you were talking
about everyone assumes they're extremely
conscientious and patriotic and all that
but
they
probably
should not have in their heads
conscientious and patriotic and all that
but they
probably
should not have in their heads
information that
as my colleague suggested they don't
really need to know to do this broader
job
advise the president
information that as my colleague
suggested they don't really need to know
to do this broader job
advise the president
in a proper congressional role on the
broad issues of our national policy
thank you thank you very much thank you
thank you
in a proper congressional role on the
broad issues of our national policy
thank you thank you very
thank much mr chairman
i think we can agree too that disclosure
by
congress or
exec thank you mr chairman
i think we can agree too that disclosure
by
congress or
executive people sometimes
is innocent it cannot be needn't be
malicious but inadvertent if you know
something i want security of people
sometimes is innocent it cannot be
needn't be malicious but inadvertent if
you know something i once
confess i made a statement on the floor
about a specific
matter that was a secret uh and um
confess i made a statement on the floor
about a specific
matter that was a secret uh and
i didn't realize what i had said or done
till the press called me and asked me if
i really meant what i said
and it suddenly dawned on me that then
i'd used a number i didn't realize what
i had said or done till the press called
me and asked me if i really meant what i
said
and it suddenly dawned on me that then i
had used a number uh it would cost so
much to accomplish a certain thing and
that was classified so uh that's part of
the problem um the canai uh it would
cost so much to accomplish a certain
thing and that was
classified so
that's part of the problem um the
canadian embassy i dare say would just
assume this never got disclosed in in
many ways at least the people that still
have to be over there indian embassy i
dare say would just assume this never
got disclosed in in many ways at least
the people that still have to be over
there inside iran although the people
who were heroic i'm sure
had mixed feelings about having their
heroism
inside iran although the people who were
heroic i'm sure
had mixed feelings about having their
heroism
kept under a a bushel but i can
understand where sometimes these things
just as soon never get disclosed and
everybody's the happier also on the kept
under a bushel but i can understand
where sometimes these things just as
soon never get disclosed and everybody's
the happier also on the iran thing uh
admiral i would think
that in addition to the lives or maybe
it was you mr kobe the lives that the
administration iran thing uh admiral i
would think
that in addition to the lives or maybe
it was you mr colby the lives that the
administration used as justification of
the hostages the the involvement of a
third country participating might have
been another reason for
for keeping this cruised as
justification of the hostages the the
involvement of a third country
participating might have been another
reason for
for keeping this quiet um
i think we can agree
we need mutual trust between the
executive and the hill there is a lack
of quiet um
i think we can agree
we need mutual trust between the
executive and the hill there is a lack
of mutual trust between the executive
and the hill
we have some justification for
questioning
the forthrightness of sexual trust
between the executive and the hill
we have some justification for
questioning
the forthrightness of some of the things
we've heard from the administration as
well as some of the things we've not
heard from the administration but the
executive too has a some of the things
we've heard from the administration as
well as some of the things we've not
heard from the administration but the
executive too has a lot of justification
for being skeptical about our ability to
keep a secret and once more
i sound like i'm promoting your book a
lot of justification for being skeptical
about our ability to keep a secret and
once more
i sound like i'm promoting your book mr
colby and i am
page 423
thus by mid-1975 appearances on the hill
had become approved mr colby and i am
page 423
thus by mid-1975 appearances on the hill
had become a pervasive aspect of my job
as dci and i was going up there to
report on every new step taken in the
angola kurdish and other covert
operations currently invasive aspect of
my job is dci and i was going up there
to report on every new step taken in the
angola kurdish and other covert
operations currently underway as well as
testifying on practically everything the
cia had ever done during the last three
decades to the select committee's
investigating intelligence there's the
important way as well as testifying on
practically everything the cia had ever
done during the last three decades to
the select committees investigating
intelligence here's the important part
sadly the experience demonstrated that
secrets if they are to remain secret
cannot be given to more than a few
congressmen
every part sadly the experience
demonstrated that secrets if they are to
remain secret cannot be given to more
than a few congressmen
every new project subjected to this
procedure during 1975 leaked and the
covert part of cia's covert action
seemed three new projects subjected to
this procedure during 1975 leaked and
the covert part of cia's covert action
seemed almost gone
i have
been unfair
somewhat unintentionally to admiral
turner because he's almost gone
um i have
been unfair
uh somewhat unintentionally to admiral
turner because you two have a great book
secrecy and democracy and uh i am uh
chagrined that i don't have it with me
today i shall have it next week even
though you won't be too have a great
book secrecy and democracy and uh i am
uh chagrined that i don't have it with
me today i shall have it next week even
though you won't be here point of order
mr congressman i have several books and
you haven't mentioned any of them the
reason yours aren't here ray are they're
too heavy to carry
point of order mr congressman i have
several books and you haven't mentioned
any of them the reason yours aren't here
ray or they're too heavy to carry
but um i would um i would like to ask um
well i want to thank you admiral turner
for you're great
but um i would um i would like to ask um
well i want to thank you admiral turner
for your great testimony and i'm sorry
you left out the parts you did because i
i thought they were excellent as well
and i hope every member of this uh
subcommittee will read the testimony and
the i'm sorry you left out the parts you
did because i i thought they were
excellent as well and i hope every
member of this
subcommittee will read the the
classified annex as well
and i thank you for your letter to me of
january 27th
last year supporting the
concept of the classified annex as well
and i thank you for your letter to me of
january 27th
last year supporting the
concept of a joint intelligence
committee um and i would like to offer
this letter in the record if i may uh to
be a part of this record from admin the
joint intelligence committee um and i
would like to offer this letter in the
record if i may uh to be a part of this
record from admiral turner supporting
that
and i have another letter from richard
helms
commenting on h.r 1013 turner's
supporting that
and i have another letter from richard
helms
commenting on h.r 1013 and also
supporting the joint committee concept
rather strongly i'd like to offer that
for the record
and
and also supporting the joint uh
committee concept rather strongly i'd
like to offer that for the record
and uh i would like to ask uh you uh mr
colby if you
also support the notion of a single
select committee to i would like to ask
you mr colby if you
also support the notion of a single
select committee on intelligence made of
senators and house members uh smaller
staff a smaller membership select people
if that might not fit on intelligence
made of senators and house members
smaller staff a smaller membership
select people
if that might not facilitate this
development of mutual trust and
confidence and disclosure that we
women i all
support it and i very much
facilitate this development of mutual
trust and confidence and disclosure that
we all
recognize we fully support it and i very
much
applaud you for the effort to launch it
thank you thank you and ray klein i'm
you have already fortunately you
initiated mentioning it and i i love you
for the effort to launch it thank you
thank you and ray klein i'm you have
already fortunately you initiated
mentioning it and i i take it you
haven't changed your mind in the last
few minutes no you haven't dissuaded me
i think i think it's a good idea but i i
would also like to add though i think
the two separate take it you haven't
changed your mind in the last few
minutes no you haven't dissuaded me i
think
i think it's a good idea but i would
also like to add though i think the two
separate committees can do a good job
and that's why i feel it's so important
to develop that better spirit of
cooperation on intelligence planning
committees can do a good job and that's
why i feel it's so important to develop
that better spirit of cooperation on
intelligence planning that we've all
spoken about thank you i think mr
chairman you've been most kind and
indulgent i'm not a member of this
subcommittee and you've you've been
you've that we've all spoken about thank
you i think mr chairman you've been most
kind and indulgent i'm not a member of
this subcommittee and you've you've been
you've permitted me to be here well it's
always a pleasure to have you mr hyde
although i sense a campaign underway
here for a joint committee
two years now
permitted me to be here well it's always
a pleasure to have you mr hyde although
i sense a campaign underway here for a
joint committee
two years now it's a third year yeah
uh mr castenward
thank you mr chairman now that all three
of you have been co-opted by mr hyde why
it's a third year yeah
mr castenmark
thank you mr chairman now that all three
of you have been co-opted by mr hyde why
i don't
know what we can say
other than
i say this about joint committee
it might be
thinkable
you know what we can say
other than
say this about joint committee
it might be
thinkable some particular point in time
but i suggest it is not now thinkable
if two separate committees can't render
proper oversight some particular point
in time but i suggest it is not now
thinkable
if two separate committees can't render
proper oversight
one surely won't
that's that's been the problem
throughout as a matter of fact
a joint committee is one step
one surely won't
that's that's been the problem
throughout as a matter of fact
a joint committee is one step away from
extinguishing all committees of the
congress in terms of intelligence
and and i understand that as well as
anybody else away from
extinguishing all committees of the
congress in terms of intelligence
and and i understand that as well as
anybody else
but to the extent that we still do
exercise
statutory or constitutional authority
with
but to the extent that we still do
exercise
statutory or constitutional authority
with respect to these matters
i'm
a little discouraged by
by not only say the either opposition
respect to these matters
i'm
a little discouraged by
by not only let's say the either
opposition or
such highly qualified
acceptance of any statutory change
mission or such highly qualified
acceptance of any statutory change
that i see very little gr grounds to
pursue the matter
but i do think in the light of what has
been said
that i see very little gr grounds to
pursue the matter
but i do think in the light of
what has been said
that
in admiral turner suggested
he was interested in what steps to make
oversight more vigorous that
and admiral turner suggested
he was interested in what steps to make
oversight more vigorous and effective
and as the chairman has pointed out far
more sharply than the gentleman from
illinois
it's ineffective
and as the chairman has pointed out
far more sharply than the gentleman from
illinois
a couple of real instances
major instances in which we'd been lied
to
and let us assume that this is these are
not a couple of real instances
major instances in which we'd been lied
to
and let us assume that this is these are
not unique
in the last year or two
let's assume that
um what is uh admiral turner our unique
in the last year or two
let's assume that
um what is uh admiral turner our our
alternative here
i i suggest to seek some sort of mutual
trust is is not is is not
effective our alternative here
i i suggest to seek some sort of mutual
trust is is not is is not
effective i mean that
what action can we take
to prevent that sort to bring that sort
of destructive relationship i mean that
what action can we take
to prevent that sort to bring that sort
of destructive relationship in which we
know we're lied to and have presumably
no recourse what recourse should we have
other than let us say other than to
change
this which we know we're lied to and
have presumably no recourse what
recourse should we have
other than let us say other than to
change
this particular statute
with all respect
particular statute
mr castenberger
with all respect uh
i think
when i use the word in my testimony
committee can be more rigorous
in pursuing
i think
and i use the word in my testimony the
committee can be more rigorous
in pursuing
whether the executive branch is telling
them all
and telling them honestly
uh in this instance
whether the executive branch is telling
them all
and telling them honestly
uh in this instance
long before august 1985 when it came out
that colonel north was doing something
in support of the conference
long before august 1985
when it came out that colonel north was
doing something in support of the
conference
it seems to me there was
great evidence that was not a spirit of
cooperation
on the executive branch side with
respect to oversight of intelligence
it seems to me there was
great evidence that was not a spirit of
cooperation on the executive branch side
with respect to oversight of
intelligence
therefore it seems to me
you had cause to be suspicious
when the president's own right hand men
uh therefore it seems to me
you had cause to be suspicious
when the president's own right-hand men
denied something that was obvious
that whether they were what they were
telling you was they were doing this
within the law
but it was denied something that was
obvious
that whether they were what they were
telling you was they were doing this
within the law but it was obvious they
were doing it against the spirit of the
congress of the united states against
the spirit of what the people of the
united states through the congress had
mandated no
obvious they were doing it against the
spirit of the congress of the united
states against the spirit of what the
people of the united states through the
congress had mandated no
governmental support for the countries
and was there any question in anybody's
mind that colonel north
was doing that
i don't think so
governmental support for the contras and
was there any question in anybody's mind
that colonel north
was doing that
i don't think so i remember being
incensed at the time that nothing was
being done in the media or the congress
to stop this and i remember being
incensed at the time that nothing was
being done in the media or the congress
to stop this
and uh
i'm sorry mr chairman
there's an old uh
athletic saying uh that i learned one
time when
the
i'm sorry mr chairman
uh there's an old uh
athletic saying uh
that i learned one time when
we fought notre dame from navy to a six
to six tie but ended up on the goal line
uh with a goal line stick we fought
notre dame from navy to a six to six tie
but ended up on the goal line
with a goal line stand that we thought
was heroic
and we charge into the locker room
very enthusiastic about our performance
and the coach looked at us and said
gentlemen and that we thought was heroic
and we charge into the locker room uh
very enthusiastic about our performance
and the coach looked at us and said
gentlemen
long after the deeds have been forgotten
the score will be remembered you men
tied
and
with respect sir
long after the deeds have been forgotten
the score will be remembered you men
tied
and
with respect sir
the answer was did you get to the bottom
of the case and and you didn't
the
the score is what we remember
uh uh
the answer was did you get to the bottom
of the case and and you didn't
the the score is what we remember
and i think you have to be more
more rigorous i would say with all
candor that in my four years
when i think we had a very cooperative
relationship
and i think you have to be more
more rigorous i would say with all
candor that in my four years
when i think we had a very cooperative
relationship
i think the committees of the congress
could have been more rigorous with me
and i would have appreciated it
in many ways
rigorous in pain i think the committees
of the congress could have been more
rigorous with me and i would have
appreciated it
in many ways
rigorous
in paying less attention to the details
of my budget
and
50 dollars here and 100 there
and more and asking less attention to
the details of my budget
and
50 dollars here and 100 there
and more and asking
turner are you going in the right
direction
what are your plans for the future
what is your track record on
turner are you going in the right
direction
what are your plans for the future
what is your track record on
how you used your sources in
over the last 10 years let's say in
developing
how you used your sources in
over the last 10 years let's say in
developing uh
the the uh
recommendations on iran i mean you you
ended up in a debacle on iran well
somebody should have come after that
the the
recommendations on iran i mean you you
ended up in a debacle on iran well
somebody should have come after that
from the congress and said let's go back
10 years turner and trace
what you said to people about this
what the whole community from the
congress and said let's go back 10 years
turner and trace
what you said to people about this and
what the whole community said and trace
whether your sources were good what were
you relying on 10 years ago what were
you relying on now were you using this
well
i think there's a lot more to be said
and trace whether your sources were good
what were you relying on 10 years ago
what were you relying on now were you
using this well i think there's a lot
more that you can do
if you'll take a longer range look at
what our intelligence
needs sir and
and will be helpful if you're that you
can do
if you'll take a longer range look at
what our intelligence
needs sir and uh and will be helpful if
you're probing and rigorous
i gather you wouldn't suggest a tighter
rain with respect to the budget
in the process
no idea probing and rigorous
i gather you wouldn't suggest a tighter
rain with respect to the budget
in the process
no i'd expect i would suggest a looser
rain in many ways particularly in the r
d field where they think they need
uh more freedom to go out and invent the
u2 expect i would suggest a looser rain
in many ways particularly in the r d
field where they think they need
more freedom to go out and invent the u2
again which was done in a skunk works
with
with nobody looking over their shoulder
and i'm worried today whether we have
that
again which was done in a skunk works
with with nobody looking over their
shoulder
and i'm worried today whether we have
that
inventedness that is keeping us one step
ahead of the opposition
in the technical
field
mr casper mr colby inventedness that is
keeping us one step ahead of the
opposition
in the technical
field
mr mr colby what would you recommend
well i would i've already mentioned one
if you find a case where somebody
actually lies to you there are
provisions of law by which would you
recommend uh well i would i've already
mentioned one if you find a case where
somebody actually lies to you there are
provisions of law by which that person
can be prosecuted
there are ways to do it and i think it's
a matter for the committee to take a
look at and see whether there is a
recommendation that person can be
prosecuted
there are ways to do it and i think it's
a matter for the committee to take a
look at and see whether there is a
recommendation
that action be submitted to the justice
department to follow up on such a case
secondly
traditionally this is the
that action be submitted to the justice
department to follow up on on such a
case secondly
traditionally this is the
uh house of which has control of the
purse
and while i agreed fully with admiral
turner that uh fooling around with fifty
dollars
uh house of which has control of the
purse and while i agree fully with
admiral turner that uh fooling around
with fifty dollars here or there is not
the point the fact is that uh a
congressman once asked me exactly this
question you come up and tell us one of
these things here or there is not the
point the fact is that a congressman
once asked me exactly this question you
come up and tell us one of these things
what do we do about it i said well
you've got everything you can do about
it
and if it gets back to you can express
an opposition by individual what do we
do about it i said well you've got
everything you can do about it
and if it gets back to you can express
an opposition by individually you can
get a majority vote of the committee
against it if necessary you can do as
chairman boland i think so brilliantly
did
divilly you can get a majority vote of
the committee against it if necessary
you can do as chairman boland i think so
brilliantly did
develop a resolution of the congress
which circumscribes without revealing
the specifics circumscribes the ability
of the agency to act develop a
resolution of the congress which
circumscribes without revealing the
specifics circumscribes the ability of
the agency to act that was done to me on
angola and it was done to to uh to casey
on nicaragua and if you find people
getting around that was done to me on
angola and it was done to to uh to casey
on nicaragua and if you find people
getting around that
i always thought that there was a way
you could catch the attention of the
director's
mind fairly quickly to just say well mr
director you just i always thought that
there was a way you could catch the
attention of the director's
uh mind fairly quickly just say well mr
director you just keep on going on that
but you put take your little notebook
out you put the figure 10 million
dollars down on it
because 10 million dollars is coming out
of next you just keep on going on that
but you put take your little notebook
out and you put the figure 10 million
dollars down on it
because 10 million dollars is coming out
of next year's budget and i don't care
where you distribute it but it's coming
out
that'll catch his attention and it's the
power of the purse it is
parker's budget and i don't care where
you distribute it but it's coming out
that'll catch his attention and it's the
power of the purse it is
part of the constitutional arrangement
that the congress is not helpless it has
power
thank you
thank you for the constitutional
arrangement that the congress is not
helpless it has power
thank you mr chairman
thank you mr chairman um
there's been a little there's been a lot
of comment about the 48 hour requirement
whether or not that's that's proper or
adequate or
or determined um
there's been a little there's been a lot
of comment about the 48 hour requirement
whether or not that's that's proper or
adequate or
or useful but let me go back to basics
for just a moment i'm not sure at this
point
what the feelings of each of our three
current witnesses is with respect to
useful but let me go back to basics for
just a moment i'm not sure at this point
what the feelings of each of our three
current witnesses is with respect to the
current requirement of the law that
that the congress or portions of the
congress be notified in a timely fashion
are you supportive of that of the
existing law the current requirement of
the law that
that the congress or portions of the
congress be notified in a timely fashion
are you supportive of that of the
existing law are you simply arguing
against extending it or making the
requirement more specific that is we're
talking specifically here of the 48
hours do you
are you supportive of the current are
you simply arguing against extending it
or making the requirement more specific
that is we're talking specifically here
for the 48 hours do you
are you supportive of the current
requirements of the law i support the
current one yes sir
and specifically because it has a
certain flexibility also requirements of
the law i support the current one yes
sir
yeah
mr clinton
and specifically because it has a
certain flexibility what are you also
exercised about just the 48 hours
i mean is this is this what we're
talking about the 48 hours rather than
timely fashion it's it's making the
whole process rigid rather than
exercised about just the 48 hours
i mean is this is this what we're
talking about the 48 hours rather than
timely fashion it's it's making the
whole process rigid rather than re
reflective of the real world
yeah but when you start talking and i'm
not speaking specifically to you mr cole
we've even one of the other two people
gentlemen
re reflective of the real world
yeah but when you start talking and i'm
not speaking specifically to you mr cole
we've even one of the other two people
gentlemen
you're talking about things you don't
want to tell us about anyway whether
it's timely fashion 48 hours or anything
else and i'm not sure whether we're
you're talking about things you don't
want to tell us about anyway whether
it's timely fashion 48 hours or anything
else and i'm not sure whether we're
focusing on something here we all have
established that the present law gives
certain grounds for
withholding either permanently or
temporarily
notice that the present law gives
certain grounds for
withholding either permanently or
temporarily
notice all intelligence operations for
the purpose of collection information
are excluded you pointed that out so
this is not a a a cutting
all intelligence operations for the
purpose of collection information are
excluded you pointed that out so this is
not a a a cut and dried proposition
there are the present law takes into
account uh
exceptions to notification
it dried proposition there are the
present law takes into account uh
exceptions to notification
it mandates timely notification on
covert action operations i mean i think
it's the that's defined timely i think
it's the posture of the authors of this
bill that they're not proposing anything
mandates timely notification on covert
action operations i think it's the
defined timely i think it's a posture of
the authors of this bill that they're
not proposing anything terribly radical
they're in effect trying to require
uh that the that the requirements of
existing law are complied with by saying
all right you folks don't mean terribly
radical they're in effect trying to
require
uh that the the requirements of existing
law are complied with by saying all
right you folks don't seem to know what
timely means we'll tell you it's 48
hours we will agree that should be
something other than 48 hours but i'm
just trying to get some feel as to
whether or not you're offended even by
the requirements of existing to know
what timely means we'll tell you it's 48
hours we will agree that it should be
something other than 48 hours but i'm
just trying to get some feel as to
whether or not you're offended even by
the requirements of existing law where
there's this 48 hours that's well that's
causing so many eight hours because
there are situations that we've both
mentioned
which would be far beyond 48 law where
there's this 48 hours that's well that's
causing so many eight hours because
there are situations that we've both
mentioned
which would be far beyond 48 hours well
let me let me go on if i may mr chairman
i'm just trying to
since this is the legislative
subcommittee and again long mr hyde i
apologize i'm not a member of this
distinguished subcommittee
well let me let me go on if i may mr
chairman i'm just trying to
since this is the legislative
subcommittee and again along with mr
hyde i apologize i'm not a member of
this distinguished subcommittee which
wish i were but the question for us or
at least eventually for the full
committee at the moment for this
subcommittee is whether we should be
changing the law and if so how we should
be changing
wish i were but the question for us or
at least eventually for the full
committee at the moment for this
subcommittee is whether we should be
changing the law and if so how we should
be changing it you know what we should
be doing and we've had some useful
suggestions or tried to be helpful
suggestions that
witnesses have tried to to get you know
what we should be doing and we've had
some useful suggestions or tried to be
helpful suggestions that that
witnesses have tried to to
be helpful with uh admiral turner spoke
about this risk of life criterion and
and and putting one's life on the line
as some have suggested be helpful with
uh admiral turner spoke about this risk
of life criterion and and and putting
one's life on the line as some have
suggested that may not be a terribly
useful criterion at least not as a sole
criterion
as i mentioned earlier and i think
perhaps others have we are aware right
now of a number of nested that may not
be a terribly useful criterion at least
not as a sole criterion
as i mentioned earlier and i think
perhaps others have we are aware right
now of a number of intelligence
operations
which we cannot even describe of course
in which people's lives are on the line
right now we all know about them i mean
all of us on this committee so that
can't intelligence operations which we
cannot even describe of course in which
people's lives are on the line right now
we all know about them i mean all of us
on this committee so that can't you know
that can't be the sole criterion uh
we've discussed that that it
does not include under existing law
intelligence gathering operations so if
we you know that can't be the sole
criterion uh we've discussed it that it
does not include under existing law
intelligence gathering operations so if
we were to be parachuting mr colby into
soviet union this time perhaps instead
of france or whoever i'd rather not i
understand
um we're we're not we're not going to be
parachuting mr colby into soviet union
this time perhaps instead of france or
wherever i'd rather not i
understand
we're not we're not really talking about
that either um
mr colby suggested something uh a
criterion which i i personally found you
know not really talking about that
either
mr colby suggested something a criterion
which i i personally found you know more
useful that is the need to know
uh it's not even so much need to know
but i guess should we know should
congress know about these sorts of
things just in terms of the kind of more
useful that is the need to know
uh it's not even so much need to know
but i guess should we know should
congress know about these sorts of
things just in terms of the common sense
approach to it uh and where we go back
to the examples that the admiral gave
all of which were hostage rescue related
kinds of things which i again personally
suggest common sense approach to it uh
and where we go back to the examples
that the admiral gave all of which were
hostage rescue related kinds of things
which i again personally suggested
earlier i don't think we need to know i
don't think we particularly should know
or or care about knowing but you could
say under mr colby's criterion also need
to know should we know no we don't know
earlier i don't think we need to know i
don't think we particularly should know
or or care about knowing but you could
say under mr kobe's criterion also need
to know should we know no we don't need
to know
yeah the iran thing was a hostage thing
now now you you may say it wasn't but
now you can't have it both ways either
you need to know yeah the iran thing was
a hostage thing now now you you may say
it wasn't but now you can't have it both
ways either reagan was interested in
arms for the hostages or he wasn't so
you can't just say that the hostage
thing is different your earlier
interruptions of me were useful this is
reagan was interested in arms for the
hostages or he wasn't so you can't just
say that henry's a hostage thing is
different your earlier interruptions of
me were useful this is not terribly
useful i'm not talking about an extended
policy change of selling interruption of
you is always useful thank you
not terribly useful i'm not talking
about an extended policy change of
selling interruption of you is always
useful thank you
i speak more kindly of you than you do
with me
i'm just retaliating
right sorry okay this is a bigger thing
we're not talking about sending people
into the i speak more kindly of you than
you do with me
just retaliating
right sorry okay this is a bigger thing
we're not talking about sending people
into the desert to rescue hostages and
you know it's gonna be done within 48
hours we're talking about a big policy
change as everybody has
has agreed to anyway i'm just saying
under mr colby suggested to rescue
hostages and you know it's going to be
done within 48 hours we're talking about
a big policy change as everybody has has
has agreed to anyway i'm just saying
under mr colby's suggested criteria of
need to know or should we know uh i
would agree in terms of applying to the
three examples the only three examples
that the admiral admiral turner gave to
us just a criterion of need to know or
should we know uh i would agree in terms
of applying to the three examples the
only three examples that the admiral
admiral turner gave to us we don't need
to know you guys don't need to tell us
go ahead good luck we hope that it turns
out all right but you get to other
things though especially policy related
things and i talk i think we're talking
about something we don't need to know
you guys don't need to tell us go ahead
good luck we hope that it turns out all
right but you get to other things though
especially policy related things and i
talk i think we're talking about
something else and what what worries me
mr colby my friend is that i got the
example you started giving made me a
little bit uneasy because you started
talking about penetration for political
purposes and what worries me mr colby my
friend is that i got the example you
started giving made me a little bit
uneasy because you started talking about
penetration for political purposes
and mr klein was talking about various
opportunities which might be lost if if
we if the folks in the cia and elsewhere
knew that you know certain number of
folks over here and mr klein was talking
about various opportunities which might
be lost if if we if the folks in the cia
and elsewhere knew that you know a
certain number of folks over here had to
be had to be told now you're getting now
you're raising some warning flags it
seems to me and you know you're talking
i don't know what you're talking about
what are you talking about you're
talking about getting somebody involved
in someone's how to be how to be told
now you're getting now you're raising
some warning flags it seems to me and
you know you're talking i don't know
what you're talking about what are you
talking about you're talking about
getting somebody involved in someone's
government who may eventually have
something to do with overthrowing the
government or what are we talking about
and why shouldn't those policy-related
things be told at least to the eight
members of these committees government
who may eventually have something to do
with overthrowing the government or what
are we talking about and why shouldn't
those policy-related things be told at
least to the eight members of these
committees into the leadership that
under the existing law
mr billingson i think your points are
well taken i
i fully supported the effort by this the
leadership that under the existing law
mr billings and i think your points are
well taken i
i fully supported the effort by this
committee some years ago to try to write
a new charter for the intelligence
community and i think we all kind of
gave up on it i mean it was so committee
uh some years ago to try to write a new
charter for the intelligence community
and i think we all kind of gave up on it
i mean it was so complicated and so
difficult that the thing just kind of
disappeared and it's been replaced by
these individual actions all of which i
complicated and so difficult that the
thing just kind of
disappeared and it's been replaced by
these individual actions all of which i
fully agree amendments to the existing
law
correcting problems that have arisen
from time to time i think you get the
same thing when you try to fully agree
amendments to the existing law
correcting problems that have arisen
from time to time i think you get the
same thing when you try to explain a
need to know if you try to define a need
to know you'll get a very great
difference of opinion by different
onlookers as to what he explained a need
to know if you try to define a need to
know you'll get a very great difference
of opinion by different onlookers as to
what he needs to know and what he
doesn't
and it immediately gets transferred into
do you have faith in me
which is not the question the question
is he needs to know and what he doesn't
and it immediately gets transferred into
do you have faith in me
which is not the question the question
is does he have a need to know
then
how can you define that i've clearly one
side of it
is a clear power does he have a need to
know
then
how can you define that i've clearly one
side of it
is a clear policy change
the other side of it is the identity of
an agent
uh
sometimes the mere and see change
the other side of it is the identity of
an agent
sometimes the mere insertion of an agent
can create a policy problem
i went to henry kissinger one time
and said that i knew he was engaged
version of an agent can create a policy
problem
i went to
henry kissinger one time
and said that i knew he was engaged in a
very delicate negotiation and with a
foreign country at the same time we had
hopes of recruiting an officer of that
country
and i just in a very delicate
negotiation and with a foreign country
the same time we had hopes of recruiting
an officer of that country
and i just wanted to make sure that if
if uh
if it blew up in our face as you have to
anticipate that he it wouldn't upset his
thing he said go ahead wanted to make
sure that if if
if it blew up in our face as you have to
anticipate
that he it wouldn't upset his thing he
said go ahead you do your business fine
but at least i was sensitive to the fact
that he did need to know that there was
a very substantial risk to it you do
your business fine but at least i was
sensitive to the fact that he did need
to know
that there was a very substantial risk
to his policy being adopted in the
actions i was taking now that was a mere
agent recruitment
issue and if you try to define it
his policy being adopted in the actions
i was taking now that was a mere agent
recruitment issue and if you try to
define it in words i think you'd have a
very difficult time with it
i mean i think if you know the more you
talk about these things the more you
come to agreement even though the one in
words i think you'd have a very
difficult time with it
i mean i think if you know the more you
talk about these things the more you
come to agreement even though one might
start on on different on different sides
as to pretty much exactly
what it is that we ought to be told
about i mean that the particular
instance you might start on on different
on different sides as to pretty much
exactly
what it is that we ought to be told
about i mean the particular instance you
were speaking of course we shouldn't
know
um the hostage
i would say to my my friend mr hyde that
that
we were talking about a vast champion of
course we shouldn't know
um the hostage
i would say to my my friend mr hyde that
that
we were talking about a vast change in
policy obviously not only with respect
to supplying arms for hostages but
quite different from the problems that
admiral turner faced where we had some
americans over there who were ancient
policy obviously not only with respect
to supplying arms for hostages but
quite different from the problems that
admiral turner faced where we had some
americans over there who were posted
over there by their government who were
serving us and we had every
responsibility to do what we possibly
could to help them out or to get them
out if that had to be
posted over there by their government
who were serving us and we had every
responsibility to do what we possibly
could to help them out or to get them
out if had had to be by rescuing them
it's quite a different policy which the
congress should have been spoken to
should have been discussed with uh
and was not with respect to the rescuing
them it's quite a different policy which
the congress should have been spoken to
should have been discussed with
uh
and was not with respect to the iranian
situation the more recent iranian
situation where you have private
american individuals who to be blunt
about it had no business being over
there and who's and the president of
this iranian situation the more recent
iranian situation where you have private
american individuals who to be blunt
about it had no business being over
there and who's and the president of
this country had no right holding that
holding hostage the foreign policy of
this great country of 230 million people
because some americans who were not sent
there by us were not serving us in the
country had no right holding that
holding hostage the foreign policy of
this great country of 230 million people
because some americans who were not sent
there by us were not serving us in the
cia or the state department decided they
want to go to beirut for their own good
purposes which was fine and good we
should help them if we possibly can but
it's a totally different situation than
the one the admirals than the admiral
faye or the state department decided
they want to go to beirut for their own
good purposes which was fine and good we
should help them if we possibly can but
it's a totally different situation than
the one the admirals than the admiral
faced in my opinion five six seven years
ago
never again
and i thank you mr chairman the book
that has been admirably prepared by your
staff and given to all of us to discuss
this
and i thank you mr chairman the book
that has been admirably prepared by your
staff and given to all of us to discuss
this
suggested new bill
has an interesting paragraph on page
nine executive branch practice as far as
we know since enactment of the
suggested new bill
has an interesting paragraph on page
nine executive branch practice as far as
we know since enactment of the oversight
act in the fall of 1980 the committee
has been given notice prior to
implementation of all findings except
for the january oversight act in the
fall of 1980 the committee has been
given notice prior to implementation of
all findings except for the january 17
1986 iran finding in addition as far as
we know all covert actions carried out
since 1980 again with the exception of
the 17 1986 iran finding in addition as
far as we know all covert actions
carried out since 1980 again with the
exception of the pre-january 17 86 iran
arms transfer activities have been the
subject of findings there has been one
occasion since enactment of the
oversight pre-january 17 86 iran arms
transfer activities have been the
subject of findings there has been one
occasion since enactment of the
oversight act when prior notice was
given only to the chairman and ranking
minority member of the committee and one
occasion when notice was limited to the
designated leadership group i'd act when
prior notice was given only to the
chairman and ranking minority member of
the committee and one occasion when
notice was limited to the designated
leadership group so i think that sets
the context the environment for for this
hearing that we are talking about one
aberrational and i concede aberrational
so i think that sets the context the
environment for for this hearing that we
are talking about one aberrational and i
concede aberrational act by the
administration the executive and and i
just wonder if we're not overreacting
and that's the point i want to make
thank you
thank you act by the administration the
executive and and i just wonder if we're
not overreacting and that's the point i
want to make thank you
thank you
i think this has been a very uh helpful
discussion and i think
the dialogue between the panel and mr
bielensen has been especially
i think this has been a very uh helpful
discussion and i think
the dialogue between the panel and mr
bielenson has been especially
interesting
i assume based on what's been said that
all of you agree
that the committees the intelligence
committees of the congress interesting
i assume based on what's been said that
all of you agree
that the committees the intelligence
committees of the congress or in some
limited cases the gang of eight
should be advised
about any policy change
or in some limited cases the gang of
eight
should be advised
about any policy change
albeit in covert form
when that's decided upon by the
president
i think the first you all agree with
that i assume
uh and i think might be it in covert
form
when that's decided upon by the
president
i think the frustr you all agree with
that i assume
uh and i think most of us would agree mr
klein that we don't have to have our
heads full of all of the details of
every single covert operation that's the
other extreme and as mr bus would agree
mr klein that we don't have to have our
heads full of all of the details of
every single covert operation that's the
other extreme and as mr bielenson has
said we don't need to know all of that
it's the policy
formulation that really is the critical
area and the frustration some of us feel
mr bielensen has said we don't need to
know all of that it's the policy
formulation that really is the critical
area and the frustration some of us feel
in this particular case at least and i
think that some of the senators felt on
both sides of the aisle in the case of
the mining of harbors in nicaragua
in this particular case at least and i
think that some of the senators felt on
both sides of the aisle in the case of
the mining of harbors in nicaragua
is that when you have an administration
some of whose members
are prepared not to tell the truth on
policy issues
is that when you have an administration
some of whose members
are prepared not to tell the truth on
policy issues
you have an administration that will
read timely notice
in a very liberal
way to say the least
uh
you have an administration that will
read timely notice
uh in a very liberal way to say the
least
now as you said mr colby you can punish
people who lie to you
about policy matters
but there's not much
as you said mr colby you can punish
people who lie to you about policy
matters
but there's not much
there's not much
resource available to us as mr
castenmeyer said
where a pres
there's not much
resource available to us as mr
castenmeyer said
where a president and his administration
chooses to disregard timely notice
because as you said mr klein it's a very
flexible term
and therefore the resident and his
administration chooses to disregard
timely notice because as you said mr
klein it's a very flexible term
and therefore the remedy
is for us is very difficult and it's out
of that
concern that this bill is before us
i think you've already some interesting
remedy is for us is very difficult and
it's out of that
concern
that this bill is before us i think
you've all raised some interesting
points and i think have helped us to
wander through this difficult issue and
i'm sure i speak for all the members of
the committee and thanking you for being
with us points and i think have helped
us to
wander through this difficult issue and
i'm sure i speak for all the members of
the committee and thanking you for being
with us today
i would like to before we adjourn to ask
unanimous consent to insert in the
hearing record letters concerning hp
i would like before we adjourn to ask
unanimous consent to insert in the
hearing record letters concerning h.r
1013 that the committee has received
from cyrus vance mcgeorge bundy and
admiral turner
uh two memoranda concerning the
constitutionality of a prior reporter
1013 that the committee has received
from cyrus vance mcgeorge bundy and
admiral turner
uh two memoranda concerning the
constitutionality of a prior reporting
requirement which was prepared by mr ray
collada senior specialist in american
law at the library of congress and
letters to the committee from professing
requirement which was prepared by mr ray
collada senior specialist in american
law at the library of congress and
letters to the committee from professor
william van alstein duke university law
school and professor lawrence tribe of
the harvard law school again thank you
to all of the witnesses and to my
colleagues on the committee sir william
van alstein duke university law school
and professor lawrence tribe of the
harvard law school again thank you to
all of the witnesses and to my
colleagues on the committee
the committee is now adjourned and will
resume its hearings next week at the
same time
the committee is now adjourned and will
resume its hearings next week at the
same time
i'll get some witnesses and support
thanks very much